schönen guten Morgen ihnen und Thorsten
frei ist bei uns der dasselbe Amt inne
hat in der Unionsfraktion Frau Mast das
sind alles andere als normale Zeiten
Krieg Klimakrise Corona ist auch noch
nicht ganz weg
sie werden gleich sagen wir haben
trotzdem Ende ist schon nicht viel
erreicht trotz all dieser schwierigen
Zeiten gibt es aber trotzdem einen Punkt
ein Thema ein Vorhaben von dem sie sagen
das ist leider zu kurz gekommen nicht so
ausgefüllt worden wie wir es uns
vorgestellt haben
naja zuerst mal haben wir vielen Dank
erstmal guten Morgen erstmal haben wir
ja schon sehr viel angepackt in dieser
Koalition und wirklich auch einen großen
Reformstau aufgelöst in schwierigsten
Zeiten das haben sie ja angesprochen uns
geht's um den Zusammenhalt wir haben
über fast toten über ist falsch aber
fast 100 Gesetzesvorhaben auf den Weg
gebracht das ist eine beachtliche
Leistung in dieser Ampelkoalition wo wir
gemeinsam das Land nach vorne bringen
und uns geht's vor allen Dingen auch
darum in schwierigen Zeiten des Land
zusammenzuhalten die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu entlasten aber auch
systematisch in die Energiepreise
einzugreifen und da werden wir diese
Woche auch noch mal den Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung bekommen das hatte
ich ihnen quasi ja schon vorab auf dem
Silbertablett serviert dass sie sagen
werden wir haben mehr geschafft als als
viele sagen aber gibt es trotzdem Punkt
wo sie sagen schade da hat uns die Krise
gehindert mehr zu tun nein die Krise hat
uns nicht gehindert mehr zu tun sondern
wir haben mehr getan und natürlich haben
wir noch viele Vorhaben vor uns zum
Beispiel die Kindergrundsicherung in
wichtiges Vorhaben aber das war schon
immer klar dass das erst später kommt
ähm die Stabilisierung der Renten
beispielsweise und vieles weitere aber
wir haben ja tatsächlich gerade in der
Energiepolitik Dinge vorgefunden die
gastspeicher waren leer als wir die
Regierung übernommen haben es gab keinen
Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien das waren
ja riesenreform Stars und das sind wir
überall dran und auf dem Platz sie haben
vielerlei Sie und Ihre Fraktion auf
jeder der Kritik geübt Vorhaben und der
Koalition dass sie legitim und sogar
auch unsere Aufgabe gibt es trotzdem ein
Thema oder ein Feld wo sie sagen so viel
dramatisch besser hätten auch wir das
nicht hingekriegt also erstens wunder
mich wundere ich mich ein bisschen wenn
die Frau Mast von Reformstau spricht
denn die SPD hat ja nicht die Regierung
übernommen sondern die SPD hat seit
vielen vielen Jahren mitregiert in
diesem Land zweiter Punkt ist der ja man
muss glaube ich einfach anerkennen dass
wir in ganz besonderen Zeiten der
multiplen Krisen sind der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine die
Auswirkungen auf die Energie
Versorgungssicherheit auch die
Energiepreise das hat ganz starke innen
und wirtschaftspolitische auch
sozialpolitische Implikationen das sind
besondere Herausforderungen aber was ich
kritisieren würde ist das in einer
solchen Zeit der zeitenwände wie es der
Bundeskanzler formuliert hat eben auch
eine entsprechende Schwerpunktsetzung
Priorisierung da sein muss ich finde
gerade nicht dass man sein Programm
einfach abarbeiten darf als wäre nichts
gewesen und jede Krise dann in
Sondervermögen als Schulden obendrauf
kommen sondern jetzt käme es eigentlich
darauf an die richtigen Schwerpunkte zu
setzen setzen sie die falschen
Schwerpunkte Frau Mast
glaube ich nicht mehr einig ob wir die
richtigen Schwerpunkte setzen
einmal aber ich will schon noch mal
sagen in welcher Lage das Land war und
warum ich Reformstau und auch von
Vernachlässigung beispielsweise der
bundeswehrspreche wir haben
keine Bundeswehr übernommen die
im Verteidigungsfall und dem bundesfall
so ausgerüstet wäre dass wir das können
das hat war viele Jahre in Verantwortung
der Union und deshalb kann ich das auch
hier mit Fug und Recht haben und ich
möchte den zweiten Portemonnaie nicht
ganz kurz weil ich lass das so nicht
stehen der zweite Punkt ist dass wir
zwar mit der Union immer auf unser
Bestreben aus Atomkraft ausgestiegen
sind und auch ähm
kohleausstiegsdatum festgelegt haben
aber wir haben die Union hatte nie die
auch mit uns den Weg zu gehen nach vorne
in die Investition in regenerative
Energien und Alternativen und ich habe
ganz bewusst die Gasspeicher
angesprochen ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister der zulässt
dass die Gasspeicher bei fast Null sind
wenn er das Ministerium übergibt da kann
man schon von Reformstau sprechen sie
kommt gleich daran keine Sorge ich
wollte trotzdem die Punkte den sie
vorhin gemacht haben auch an der Stelle
nochmal aufnehmen er hat Thorsten
Freiheit ja recht wenn er sagt sie haben
ja mit regiert viele Jahre in der großen
Koalition machen sich ein bisschen zu
einfach zu sein die sind Schuld also
zuerst mal war der Bundeskanzler oder
die Bundeskanzlerin hatte die
cdu-parteifarbe und ich habe gerade
ausschließlich über schwarze Ressorts
gesprochen in der Vergangenheit und es
liegt dann schon auch in der
fachverantwortung der Ministerin und
Minister für ihre Ressorts die richtigen
Punkte nach vorne zu bringen aber das
ist Vergangenheit Bewältigung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger heute ist wichtig
wir lassen sie in der Krise nicht allein
niemand wir gehen die Gas und
Strompreises systematisch an und wir
nehmen die Dinge in die Hand wo wir
Deutschland zukunftsfähig nach vorne
entwickeln und deshalb ist so wichtig
eben beides zu tun die Krise mit hohem
Engagement zu managen und die Dinge nach
vorne zu bringen und gleichzeitig die
anderen großen Reformvorhaben auf den
Weg zu bringen wie diese Woche dann auch
das Bürgergeld haben
noch was mit auf den Weg noch ein Punkt
nämlich die Frage sie haben weil sie die
sondertöpfe erwähnt haben die ja auch
sehr kritisiert werden weil sie
außerhalb des regulären Haushalts
stattfinden können wir vielleicht auch
noch mal genauer darauf gucken wie ein
System gelöst diese Krisen und die
Kosten die durch diese Krisen entstanden
sind also wir hätten eine andere
Schwerpunktsetzung vorgenommen an einem
Sonntag Vermögen haben wir übrigens
mitgewirkt eben nämlich dem
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr und es
bringt mich zu dem Punkt den die Frau
Mast angesprochen hat auch ich möchte
nicht in die Vergangenheit schauen und
die Frage stellen wer denn die
Beschaffung von bewaffnungsfähigen
Drohnen verhindert hat wer die
Ausfinanzierung von zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts für die Bundeswehr
verhindert hat sondern möchte einfach
die Frage stellen warum in dieser
Situation entgegen der Ankündigungen des
Bundeskanzlers der
Verteidigungsetat gegenüber dem Vorjahr
sogar um etwa 300 Millionen Euro sinken
wird also wenn das alles stimmen würde
was die Frau Mast gerade vorgetragen hat
dann müsste die Bundesregierung und die
sie tragenden Fraktionen doch jetzt
deutlich mehr in diesem Bereich
investieren tun sie aber nicht und um
Ihre Frage zu beantworten am Ende geht
zum Schwerpunktsetzung wir haben die
Situation dass die Bundesregierung in
diesem Jahr etwa 500 Milliarden Euro
neue Kredite aufnimmt das ist so viel
wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in
den ersten 40 Jahren ihres Bestehens
aufgenommen hat ja jetzt sagen Sie auch
das war falsch aber sie sagen nicht was
die Alternative gewesen wäre aus ihrer
Sicht ja wir hätten bestimmt
wir hätten also wir hätten investiert in
die Zukunftsfähigkeit des Standortes wir
hätten weniger Kredite aufgenommen und
wir hätten natürlich auch einige
Maßnahmen so nicht gemacht
beispielsweise wenn Sie es etwas konkret
haben möchten wenn Sie etwa an das 9
euro-ticket Denken des 49 euro-ticket
was sicherlich eine gute Sache ist aber
man muss dafür auch das Geld haben und
da hätten wir eher in die Infrastruktur
in die Verkehrsinfrastrukturen des
Schienennetz in die Bestellung von
Wagenmaterial investiert als in die
Subventionierung von Preisen so viele
Stichworte bekommen auf diese reagieren
kann bitte schön vielen Dank also zuerst
will ich noch mal sagen dass unsere
Entlastungsmaßnahmen und
es steht der CDU ja offen die
entsprechenden Änderungsanträge heute zu
machen und es alles dann zu Abstimmung
zu stellen oder beziehungsweise am
Freitag was sie ja so nicht tut das ist
ja dann auch schon mal bemerkenswert
aber uns geht es darum dass wir das Land
nach vorne entwickeln wir investieren
auch mit diesem Haushalt so stark wie
noch nie zuvor also das heißt die ganzen
Zukunftsinvestitionen machen wir
zusätzlich zu den Entlastungen und den
vielen Vorhaben die wir haben und gerade
in der Verkehrspolitik finde ich ein
bisschen lächerlich dass mein Kollege
frei
ausgerechnet diesen dieses Beispiel
herbeizitiert weil gerade da haben wir
ein riesen Aufholbedarf beim Ausbau des
öpnvs beim Ausbau
schienenverschienengebundene
Infrastruktur und so weiter und deshalb
ist es 9 € Tickets das ja nur drei
Monate gab dann das 49 Euro Ticket in
Zukunft einfach ein wichtig diese Signal
und wir vernachlässigen dabei nicht
parallel den Ausbau der Infrastruktur
weil gerade im ländlichen Raum das ist
mir besonders als Baden-Württembergerin
wichtig brauchen wir auch mehr Angebot
für öffentlichen Personennahverkehr eine
bessere Vertaktung und dazu nehmen wir
auch noch mal zusätzlich Geld in die
Hand weil es ist völlig klar um vom Auto
umzusteigen brauche ich auch das
entsprechende
in ihrem gemeinsamen Bundesland
natürlich auch ganz gut und sie noch mal
wieder ja also genau das findet ja nicht
statt eine stärkere Investition in die
Infrastruktur die
Regionalisierungsmittel sollen um eine
Milliarde steigen das dürfte aber in
etwa die zusätzlichen Spritkosten
auffressen das wird die Länder nicht in
die Lage versetzen den öffentlichen
Personen Nahverkehr wirklich zu
verbessern und deswegen findet diese
Schwerpunktsetzung eben gerade nicht
statt im übrigen wir haben in diesen
Haushaltsberatungen etwa 370
Änderungsanträge auch Maßgabe Beschlüsse
gestellt wir haben uns für intensiv
eingebracht um genau diese
Schwerpunktsetzung richtig vorzunehmen
und dafür zu sorgen dass die Kredite und
die Schulden nicht weiter durch die
Decke gehen ich will nur einen Punkt
ergänzen es ist ja nicht nur alleinige
Aufgabe des Bundes den öffentlichen
Personennahverkehr auszubauen das ist
mir ganz wichtig und deshalb kann die
Union ja gerne in den Bundesländern wo
sie den Ministerpräsident stellt und
Baden-Württemberg regieren sie mit noch
mal tatkräftig zusätzliche Programme
machen um den öffentlichen
Personennahverkehr auszubauen aber
meiner Kenntnis nach wird es in
Baden-Württemberg zum Beispiel nicht
gemacht wir haben die Krisenzeiten am
Anfang auch schon mal angesprochen ihnen
beiden ist sie sind ohnehin bewusst
irgendwie es wird trotzdem auch viel im
Detail gerungen bei bei einzelnen
Punkten und ich frage mich und es wird
auch teilweise sehr scharf Argumente
argumentiert sie gehen jetzt hier sehr
sachlich miteinander um was sie sehr
angenehm finde und tauschen Argumente
aus bin habe gelegentlich den Eindruck
dass der politische Diskurs dem Ernst
der Lage nicht entsprechend würden Sie
das teilen
ich fange mit ihnen an nicht nicht
unbedingt also es ist glaube ich ganz
selbstverständlich dass sie dieses
Gespräch immer ausdrücklich ausgegeben
ja aber wir pflegen das ja auch
ansonsten durchaus im Parlament ich
glaube man muss unterscheiden zum einen
kommt es in der Krise darauf an dass man
auch in den entscheidenden Situationen
zusammensteht das haben wir auch als
Opposition so praktiziert auf der
anderen Seite darf man den
Parlamentarismus in einer solchen
Situation auch nicht ausschalten ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass die
Bürger auch merken dass es in nicht nur
Meinungsaustausch gibt sondern auch ein
Ringen um die besseren Argumente und
deswegen versuchen wir den Finger in die
Wunde zu legen darauf hinzuweisen was
nicht gut läuft und idealerweise
natürlich auch bessere Vorschläge zu
machen und das haben die Menschen dann
zu bewerten was für sie überzeugender
ist
ich glaube das ist die Aufgaben von
DemokratInnen und Demokraten ist in der
schwierigen Situation in der sich unser
Land befindet auf den Zusammenhalt zu
setzen und ich bedauere ausdrücklich
dass gerade bei der Debatte um das
Bürgergeld insbesondere von der Union
ein sehr spalterischer Ton angewandt
worden ist wo man versucht hat
geringverdienerinnen und ringverdiener
gegen diejenigen die nichts haben
auszuspielen bei gleichzeitigem nicht
zustimmen zumindestlohn wo es darum ging
das Leute die wenig verdienen mehr Geld
bekommen und da auch oft nicht mit der
Wahrheit agiert worden ist zum Beispiel
beim Thema Sanktion wird immer
unterstellt das wäre nicht ab dem ersten
Tag möglich gewesen und solche Dinge was
alles nicht stimmt das geht um in neue
Kultur des Förderns und Förderns es geht
um eine großen Auflage Weiterbildung und
es geht darum Menschen guten Arbeit zu
vermitteln also ich könnte es nicht
richtig nachvollziehen auch wenn da
immer wieder von ausspielen
unterschiedlicher Gruppen gesprochen
wird die Sozialdemokratie hat ganz
offensichtlich nicht verstanden dass man
den Euro immer nur einmal ausgeben kann
genau darum geht es letztlich und wir
haben am Ende eine Lösung gefunden die
ja sehr nahe ist an einer Lösung die der
Bundeskanzler Schröder in einer
rot-grünen Regierung einmal gemacht hat
und deswegen wundere ich mich über die
Kritik und die Sprache der SPD doch sehr
jetzt dürfen sie noch mal und da müssen
wir langsam zum Ende kommen nein bei
Bürgergeld
geht es nicht darum was Bundeskanzler
Schröder mit den Grünen übrigens damals
sehr verwässert durch den
Vermittlungsausschuss im Bundesrat durch
die cdu/csu gemacht hat sondern es geht
um einen neuen Aufschlag auf Augenhöhe
es geht um eine bessere Vermittlung in
dauerhafte Arbeit nicht jeder Job ist
okay sondern der der die Leute dauerhaft
aus der Hilfe Bedürftigkeit führt also
das ist entscheidend das ist der große
Aufschlag des Bürgergeldes und den lasse
ich mir hier auch nicht glauben
und fördern und das wird jetzt mit
diesem Kompromiss aufrecht erhalten
deswegen ist ein guter Kompromiss wir
werden dieses Thema hier morgen um 8:45
natürlich und im ganzen 15 Minuten
führen weil dann ja auch die
Entscheidung des Vermittlungsausschusses
da ist und man dann auch sagen kann in
welche Richtung ist tatsächlich gehen
wird wir sind ja noch in so einer
Vorstufe Frau Mars vielen Dank dass Sie
heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch
ihnen vielen Dank Thorsten Freise sie
müssen jetzt glaube ich relativ fix
reingehen sehe ich auf dem Monitor der
Bundeskanzler spricht jedenfalls in
dieser Sekunde schon mit dem
Oppositionsführer sehe ich da noch auf
den informellen Ring man tauscht sich da
aus und man kann offenbar auch nach wie
vor gut miteinander reden vielen Dank
sie dürfen rein ähm danke dass sie da
waren und wir gucken in den Plenarsaal
ein Bild habe ich ihn ja eben schon
angekündigt und gesagt nämlich der
Bundeskanzler im Gespräch mit ähm
Friedrich Merz und Bärbel Bass eröffnet
die Sitzung
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung haben
wir zunächst zwei Wahlen durchzuführen
im Ausschuss nach Artikel 77 Absatz 2
des Grundgesetzes der sogenannte
Vermittlungsausschuss soll auf Vorschlag
der Fraktion der cdu/csu ein Wechsel bei
der Zuordnung der persönlichen
Stellvertretung Erfolgen der Abgeordnete
Hermann Gröhe sollen nunmehr die
persönliche Stellvertretung der
Abgeordneten Antje Tillmann und die
Abgeordneten Nadine schön die
persönliche Stellvertretung für den
Abgeordneten Dr Hendrik Hoppenstedt
übernehmen sind Sie damit einverstanden
das ist der Fall dann ist die neue
Zuordnung so beschlossen weiter sollen
in den Verwaltungsrat der Kreditanstalt
für Wiederaufbau auf Vorschlag der
Fraktion der SPD der Abgeordnete Achim
Post für eine weitere Amtszeit sowie auf
Vorschlag der Fraktion der cdu/csu der
Abgeordnete Doktor andre berghäger für
eine weitere Amtszeit und der
Abgeordnete Ulrich lange als Nachfolger
für den turnusmäßig ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten Alois Karl gewählt werden
gibt es da wieder Spruch das sieht nicht
so aus dann sind die Kollegen als
Mitglieder für die neue Amtszeit gewählt
ich komme nun zur Tagesordnung am
Donnerstag soll bei den ohne Debatten
Punkten zusätzlich der Antrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu die Demokratie
stärken klare Reformen für einen
modernes und bürgernes Parlament auf
Drucksache
4.587 aufgesetzt werden
ich sehe keinen Widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen
wir setzen nun die Haushaltsberatung
fort ich rufe auf den Einzelplan 04
Bundeskanzler und Bundeskanzleramt mit
den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den Drucksachen
3.5003426
Berichterstattung haben die Abgeordneten
Otto Fricke Dennis Rohde Kerstin
Radomski Andreas audritsch Markus Bühl
und dr Gesine Lötzsch
so wie den Einzelplan 22 unabhängiger
Kontrollrat mit den
Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den Drucksachen
3.526 und
3.527 Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Dr André berghegger Martin
gersters wenn Christian Kindler Thorsten
Herbst Wolfgang wiele und dr Gesine
Lötzsch zu den zu dem Einzelplan 04
liegen 3 Änderungsanträge der Fraktion
der AFD vor außerdem werden wir später
über den Einzelplan 04 namentlich
abstimmen für die Aussprache wurde eine
Dauer von
210 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und das
Wort hat zuerst für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Friedrich Merz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren morgen am Tag
dauert der Krieg in der Ukraine nun
schon neun lange Monate
wir alle begleiten dieses Land seine
Menschen und vor allem die Soldaten im
Land mit großer Anteilnahme und
Sympathie ja mit großer Bewunderung wie
sie diesem brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieg immer noch standhalten
wir haben hier im Haus über diesen Krieg
sehr oft gesprochen wir waren uns in der
Bewertung dieses Krieges als eines
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieges
sehr weitgehend einig und ich hoffe wir
verurteilen heute gemeinsam auf das
Schärfste die Ausweitung dieses Krieges
in den letzten Tagen der sich nur noch
fast ausschließlich gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung richtet das sind
Kriegsverbrechen der schlimmsten Art für
die sich Putin und seinen Regime
irgendwann vor der Weltgemeinschaft
verantworten müssen
aufschlussreich zu sehen dass ich auf
der ganz linken und auf der ganz rechten
dieses Hauses keine Hand rührt bei
diesem Satz
bei ihnen einer ja
meine Damen und Herren dieser dieser
Krieg hat dieser Krieg
dieser Krieg hat Folgen für ganz Europa
und damit auch für unser Land
seitdem Beginn des Krieges meine Damen
und Herren diskutieren wir die
Notwendigkeit einer wirkungsvollen
Verteidigung unseres Landes und des
NATO-Bündnisses noch einmal ganz neu
jedenfalls hat sich von vielen früheren
Kritikern und Gegnern von bewaffneten
Streitkräften mittlerweile die Einsicht
durchgesetzt dass der Schutz von Frieden
und Freiheit dass der territoriale
Schutz eines Landes offenbar doch
bewaffnete abschreckungs-
Bundeskanzler
Bundeskanzler haben diese Erkenntnis
versucht umzusetzen mit ihrem Vorschlag
eines Sondervermögens für die Bundeswehr
und der Zusage ich zitiere wörtlich ab
sofort mehr als zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandproduktes unseres Landes in
die Verteidigung zu investieren
wir haben ihrem Vorschlag einer
Grundgesetzänderung zugestimmt und bei
dieser Gelegenheit mit ihnen und ihrer
Regierung eine ganze Reihe von
Vereinbarungen getroffen
so sollte unter anderem ein
parlamentarisches Gremium zum
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr eingerichtet
werden in dem laufend über die
Beschaffungsvorhaben für die Bundeswehr
beraten und berichtet wird in der bisher
einzigen Sitzung dieses Gremiums die vor
wenigen Tagen erst stattgefunden hat hat
sich ihre Koalition geweigert den
Wirtschaftsplan für die
Beschaffungsvorhaben vorzulegen die
nächste Sitzung ist jetzt geplant für
den 23 Februar des nächsten Jahres meine
Damen und Herren
wir wissen nun aus den
Haushaltsberatungen auch warum sie diese
verabredete parlamentarische
Zusammenarbeit verweigern entgegen ihrer
Zusage steigt der Verteidigungshaushalt
nämlich nicht etwa auf die verabredeten
zwei Prozent und nochmal zur Erinnerung
sie haben gesagt mindestens zwei Prozent
er singt im nächsten Jahr um fast 300
Millionen Euro Herr Bundeskanzler ich
kann es nicht anders sagen das ist ein
grober Wortbruch gegenüber dem Parlament
und vor allem gegenüber der Bundeswehr
und aus dem Sondervermögen das ja nichts
anderes ist als 100 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden dass wir im Frühjahr unter
großen Zeitdruck den siegesetzt haben
weil angeblich Beschaffungsvorhaben
nicht warten dürfen als wir dieses
Sondervermögen verabschiedet haben
müssen wir heute feststellen es ist bis
zum heutigen Tag nicht ein einziger
neuer Auftrag erteilt und nicht eine
einzige Ausschreibung veröffentlicht
worden meine Damen und Herren ein
solcher Umgang mit ihren eigenen Zusagen
Herr Bundeskanzler und der Umgang mit
unseren Partnern in der NATO und in der
Europäischen Union löst zu Recht
Befremden und erhebliches Misstrauen aus
seit dem Sommer dieses Jahres sehen wir
nun eine erhebliche Verknappung der
Energieversorgung unseres Landes und mit
dieser Verknappung sind drastische
presserhöhungen verbunden wenn die
deutsche Regierung darauf rechtzeitig
konsequent und vor allem mit den
richtigen Instrumenten reagiert hätte
dann wären die Preise immer noch
deutlich höher als vor dem Krieg aber
dann wäre es nicht zu solchen
Preisausschlägen gekommen wie wir sie
seit einigen Monaten sehen und ich will
das
einer solchen einer solchen einer
solchen Energieverknappung begegnet man
am besten und es ist ein
also wenn sie schon marktwirtschaftliche
Grundsätze nicht mehr ertragen dann
haben sie offensichtlich ein größeres
Problem mit der Bewältigung dieser Krise
als bisher von uns angenommen meine
Damen und Herren das was wir hier
erleben in diesem Jahr ist
wirtschaftlich ein klassischer
angebotsschock und einem solchen
angebotsschock begegnet man doch am
besten und am ersten mit einer
drastischen Ausweitung des angebottes
das ist ihnen sogar in Teilen gelungen
das ist ihnen beim Gas zu erheblich
überhöhten Preisen gelungen die
Gasspeicher sind gefüllt und für diesen
Winter können wir annehmen immer noch
unter der Annahme und der Hoffnung dass
der Winter möglichst nicht zu kalt
werden möge dass das auch tatsächlich
ausreichend für den nächsten Winter ist
alles offen sind alle Fragen offen und
beim Strom meine Damen und Herren beim
Strom haben Sie nicht nur die falschen
Sachverhalte zugrunde gelegt sie haben
sich ja ausschließlich auf die
sogenannte Netzstabilität konzentriert
siehe Bundeswirtschaftsminister haben
mit ihrem zweifachen Stresstest die
deutsche Öffentlichkeit und damit auch
dieses Parlament ich kann es erneut
nicht anders sagen vorsätzlich und
bewusst getäuscht mit dem was sie hier
an Zahlen vorliegt haben denn die wir
heute wissen
standen doch wie wir heute wissen er
Habeck standen doch die gewünschten
Ergebnisse in der Leitung ihres Hauses
längst fest bevor ihnen die Fachleute
das genaue Gegenteil aufgeschrieben
haben und zu diesen Fachleuten zu diesen
Fachleuten haben auch Mitglieder der
Reaktor Sicherheitskommission gehört die
ihren Unmut über den Umgang mit ihnen
auch öffentlich sehr klar und deutlich
Luft gemacht haben sie haben er habe ich
und die ganze Bundesregierung zu Beginn
ihrer Regierungszeit einen anderen Stil
einen anderen Umgang ein neues
Miteinander von Politik und
Fachexpertise zugesagt ich muss heute
feststellen diese Zusagen von ihnen
reichen gerade einmal bis zur Grenze der
eigenen Voreingenommenheit man kann auch
sagen bis zur Grenze ihre eigenen
Ideologie
und spätestens dann
spätestens dann ist es zu Ende mit ihrer
vielbeschworenen Toleranz ihrem Respekt
vor anderen Meinungen und Auffassungen
und vor allem mit ihren Respekt vor
Fachexpertise da Pfeifen sie drauf wenn
es ihrer Ideologie nicht entspricht
und dann schauen wir uns dann schauen
wir uns die Liste ihrer weiteren Zusagen
aus dem jetzt langsam zu Ende gehenden
Jahr noch einmal wenigstens in Auszügen
an sie versprechen eine
energiekostenpauschale und vergessen im
ersten Durchgang die Studentinnen und
Studenten und die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner doch sie haben es schlicht und
ergreifend vergessen nichts anderes war
es sie haben es vergessen
dann holen sie
dann holen Sie diese Zahlungen an die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner nach und Sie
können bis zum heutigen Tag die Frage
nicht beantworten ob diese Zahlungen an
die Rentner den steuerpflichtig sind
oder nicht was ist das denn für eine
Gesetzgebung die sie hier machen dann
holen sie in dieser Woche
die Zahlungen dann holen sie in dieser
Woche die Zahlungen an die Studentinnen
und Studenten nach und wissen bis zum
heutigen Tag nicht wer dieses Geld denn
überhaupt auszahlen soll keine Antwort
auf diese Frage was ist das denn für
eine Gesetz
sie sagen eine gaspreisbremse zu und
klar ist bis heute allein dass die
Dezember Vorauszahlungen vom Bund
übernommen werden sollen alles andere
bleibt trotz ihrer Beschlussfassung vom
gestrigen Tag im Unklaren die
Bevölkerung weiß bis heute nicht wann
sie aus gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse die Leistungen bekommt
die sie in ihrer Regierung versprochen
haben und dann wollen Sie dieses Geld
aus der strompreisbremse mit den
sogenannten übergewinnen finanzieren die
die Energieerzeuger in diesem Jahr und
im nächsten Jahr zahlen sollen
sie sprechen in diesem Zusammenhang
nicht von Steuern und Abgaben sondern
sie sprechen davon dieses Geld müssen
man abgreifen das ist ein Sprachgebrauch
den wir bisher jedenfalls im Steuerrecht
so nicht gekannt haben
wir wissen ja bis zum heutigen Tag
wir wissen ja bis zum heutigen Tag nicht
wo sie sich da eigentlich im
Abgabensystem unseres Landes bewegen ist
das eine Steuer ist das eine Gebühr ist
das ein Beitrag Was ist das eigentlich
was sie da machen mit diesem abgreifen
ich sage Ihnen mal voraus
sie werden mit dieser sie werden mit
dieser bekannten mit dieser geplanten
Abschöpfung genauso scheitern wie sie
mit ihrer gasumlage gescheitert sind nun
kann man das ganze abhaken meine Damen
und Herren
unter dem Stichwort handwerklich
miserables regierungshandel das ist dann
ebenso sie können es vielleicht nicht
besser das ändert sich wahrscheinlich
auch nicht das Tragische daran ist nur
dass die Lage für Millionen von
Haushalten und Menschen in diesem Land
von Tag zu Tag schwieriger wird dass
viele Menschen heute am Ende des Monats
nicht wissen wie sie das Ende des Monats
erreichen sollen und das vielen
Unternehmen mittlerweile ja wenn Sie das
Bestreiten dann nehmen Sie große Teile
dessen was im Lande stattfindet
offensichtlich nicht mehr wahr vielen
Unternehmen steht das Wasser bis zum
Hals
und verstehen Sie mich nun bitte nicht
falsch auch wenn Sie
sie wissen doch gar nicht was ich jetzt
sagen will auch wenn sie auch wenn Sie
alles richtig gemacht hätten wäre die
Lage kritisch es gibt eben für das was
jetzt zu tun ist kein Vorbild keine
Blaupause kein Regiebuch für das alles
was jetzt in einer so schwierigen Lage
eine Regierung tun muss aber ich komme
noch einmal zurück auf ihre
Regierungserklärung der Bundeskanzler
vom 27 Februar drei Tage nach
Kriegsausbruch haben Sie von dieser
Stelle aus eine wirklich bemerkenswerte
Regierungserklärung abgegeben sie haben
hier im Haus bis auf die ganz links und
bis die auf ganz rechts sie haben hier
viel Beifall ja sogar stehenden Beifall
aller Bundestagsfraktionen der Mitte
dieses Parlamentes erhalten und in
diesem Augenblick hat sich für Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler ein Zeitfenster geöffnet
sie haben es Zeiten Wände genannt der
Bundespräsident sprach vor einigen
Wochen von einem Epochenbruch aber
bleiben wir bei dem Begriff zeitenwände
mit diesem Wort haben sie in ganz
Deutschland eine große
Veränderungsbereitschaft ausgelöst weil
viele Menschen erst in diesem Augenblick
ihrer Rede gespürt haben wie ernst die
Lage nach dem Beginn des Krieges
wirklich ist und mit dieser Autorität
ausgestattet hätten sie ihr
Bundeskanzler sagen können und ich meine
sie hätten sagen müssen diese
zeitenwände ist nicht nur eine große
Herausforderung für uns sie ist auch
eine große Chance eine Chance
verkrustete Strukturen aufzubrechen eine
Chance Bürokratie abzubauen eine Chance
Prioritäten neu zu setzen lieb gewordene
Gewohnheiten abzulegen vorurteilsfrei
alle Besitzstände auf den Prüfstand zu
stellen und neben der Sicherung von
Frieden und Freiheit und das ist die
Hauptaufgabe nur eine entscheidende
Frage zu stellen was müssen wir tun um
in Deutschland und in Europa in dieser
sich jetzt abzeichnenden neuen Welt in
dieser Welt von morgen einen
wettbewerbsfähige Wirtschaft und vor
allem
produzierende Industrie und damit
zukünftige Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten
diese Frage hätten sie stellen müssen
denn dann denn genau darum
genau darum geht es jetzt und in der
näheren Zukunft auch und vor allem wie
können wir uns in Deutschland und in
Europa neben den USA und Asien vor allem
neben China als ein wettbewerbsfähiger
Industriestandort bewerten
China China ordnet den Fortschritt von
staatswegen an
die USA schütten ein Füllhorn von
US-Dollar aus sie nennen das in Flächen
reduction Act und schaffen täglich
tausende von neuen
Geschäftsmöglichkeiten
sie diskutieren und streiten immer noch
um das klein klein ihres
Koalitionsvertrages den hätten Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler beherzt zur Seite legen
müssen um anschließend in diesem Land um
Zustimmung zu werben für für eine
drastische Reduzierung unserer
Bürokratie für eine mutige Beseitigung
des in unserem Land
einzigen Unwesens der Verbandsklagen und
das richtet sich insbesondere an die
Grünen sie werden jetzt die Geister
nicht mehr los die sie selbst gerufen
haben mit dem was hier jetzt an
blockkarten und an und an
entscheidungshindernissen aufgebaut
werden
sie hätten werben müssen für einen
Masterplan Energie der nun wirklich alle
Ressourcen der Energieerzeugung
ausschöpft alle Ressourcen und nicht nur
die die sie gerne hätten aus
ideologischen Gründen ich füge hinzu für
die Nutzung auch eigene Energie
vorkommen die wir in Deutschland und in
Europa doch nun mal unstreitig haben und
auch wenn es sich sie aufregen wird ja
auch für die weiteren Nutzung der
Kernenergie jedenfalls so lange wie wir
sicher bis wir sicher sein können dass
Wind und Sonnenenergie so gespeichert
werden können dass sie grundlastfähig
sind bis dahin verbietet sich jeder
weitere Ausstieg
und dann
und ich will das ausdrücklich sagen nach
der erneut man muss es leider so sagen
gescheiterten 27
Klimakonferenz die wir in dieser Woche
gesehen haben auch für die Forschung und
Entwicklung aller erdenklichen
Technologien der CO2-Abscheidung der
CO2-Speicherung der CO2 Wiederverwertung
bis hin zu neuen Rohstoffen und
synthetischen Kraftstoffen die
Möglichkeit hätten sie gehabt das hier
zu sagen Herr Bundeskanzler und das
ganze und das Ganze für eine
gesamtheitliche Betrachtung von
Wirtschaftspolitik Energiepolitik und
Klimapolitik für ein engmaschiges
Zusammenwirken von Digitalisierung und
decarbonisierung last but not least für
erheblich beschleunigte
Genehmigungsverfahren nicht nur bei Wind
und Sonnenenergie sondern bei allen
Genehmigungsverfahren die in unserem
Lande notwendig sind und die für unsere
Volkswirtschaft
sichtbar sind das alles
was alles
wäre vielleicht verbunden gewesen mit
einer Überwindung einer Haltung die in
unserem Land leider immer nur Zweifel
und Bedenken kennt hin zu einer ich sage
Ihnen das doch wie ich es mir vorstellen
könnte hin zu einer Grundstimmung im
Land die trotz oder gerade wegen dieser
Krise
Mut fast Zuversicht annimmt und daran
glaubt dass die Ressourcen unseres
Landes noch längst nicht ausgeschöpft
sind
Herr Bundeskanzler sie hätten alle das
nach ihrer Regierungserklärung im
Februar wenigstens einmal in diesem Jahr
in einer großen Rede sagen müssen einer
Rede die die Menschen mitreißt die
Optimismus ausstrahlt und die die besten
Kräfte unseres Landes mobilisiert in
einer großen Rede wer wissen Sie wenn
Sie darüber wenn Sie das so lächerlich
finden
dann muss ich Ihnen auf dann muss ich
hier doch noch einmal einen Sachverhalt
ansprechen den ich sonst nicht
angesprochen hätte wenn Sie hier nicht
so reagieren der Bundespräsident hat das
vor einigen Wochen versucht und ich
finde er hat eine bemerkenswerte Rede
gehalten über deren Inhalt und Ziele
kann man streiten aber der
Bundespräsident der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat eine solche Rede
gehalten der Kollege dürr und ich waren
die einzigen beide Vertreter der
Bundestagsfraktion in diesem Haus die
bei dieser Rede anwesend waren kein
Mitglied der Bundesregierung kein
Parteivorsitzender außer uns beiden kein
weiterer Fraktionsvorsitzender und sie
waren eingeladen meine Damen und Herren
Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzenden sie
auf der Regierungsbank keiner von ihnen
ist zu dieser Rede des Bundespräsidenten
im Schloss Bellevue gewesen ich muss es
Ihnen leider doch sagen wenn Sie hier in
dieser Art und Weise reagieren meine
Damen und Herren stattdessen
stattdessen versinken sie mit ihrer
Koalition im ständigen Streit ihrer
Ressortminister und an einem immer
deutlicher werdenden Vertrauensverlust
der Bevölkerung und unser europäischen
Nachbarn und Freunde in die
Lösungskompetenz und in die
Verlässlichkeit dieser Bundesregierung
Herr Bundeskanzler
der Bundeskanzler vor neun Monaten
hatten sie die Chance vielleicht sogar
die historische Chance dieses Land
wirklich grundlegend zum besseren hinzu
verändern sie haben diese Chance nicht
genutzt und wahrscheinlich werden sie
nach menschlichem Ermessen jedenfalls
eine solche Chance auch nicht wieder
bekommen herzlichen Dank
Friedrich Merz der Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion hat die Generaldebatte
eröffnet hier heute im Bundestag hat den
Bundeskanzler einen groben Wortbruch
vorgeworfen was das Sondervermögen bzw
den Etat für die Bundeswehr angeht
dessen Größe und dessen Umsetzung und
vor allem handwerklich miserables
Regierungshandeln so hat er gesagt es
wird sich wohl auch bald nicht ändern
sie können es möglicherweise nicht
besser und er wirft den Bundeskanzler
vor eine wie Friedrich Merz sagt
historische Chance nicht genutzt zu
haben nämlich vom Ende Februar an die
Politik der Bundesrepublik der
Bundesregierung anders auszurichten auf
die Notwendigkeiten in vielerlei Krisen
die Erwiderung jetzt vom Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren verehrte Herr märz als
ich ihn gerade zugehört habe musste ich
an Alice im Wunderland denken
was sind Wahrheit groß ist das Reden sie
klein und umgekehrt was eigentlich
passiert ist und wer dafür
verantwortlich war das alles verschwimmt
und was zunächst logisch klingt ist in
Wahrheit blanker Unsinn
vor einem Jahr waren unsere
Energiespeicher leer wie selten zuvor
heute sind sie gefüllt bis zum Anschlag
weil diese Bundesregierung nicht nur
redet sondern handelt und weil wir im
Frühjahr zum Glück nicht ihrem Vorschlag
gefolgt sind die russischen
gastlieferung praktisch über Nacht
abzustellen
stattdessen haben wir Deutschlands
Abhängigkeit von Gas Öl und Kohle
schrittweise beendet eine Abhängigkeit
die vor einem Jahr beim Gast noch bei 50
Prozent lag und zugleich hat diese
Regierung mit einer in unserem Land gar
nicht mehr gekannten Schnelligkeit dafür
gesorgt dass Alternativen da sind in
wenigen Wochen gehen in Norddeutschland
die ersten flüssigkeitsthemals in
Betrieb
wir haben Kohlekraftwerke aus der
Reserve geholt wir lassen die drei
verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke bis ins
nächste Frühjahr weiterlaufen und wir
haben die bedeutendste Reform des
Energiesektors seit Jahrzehnten auf den
Weg gebracht
diese Bundesregierung sorgt dafür dass
die erneuerbaren Energien und die
nötigen Übertragungsnetze viel schneller
ausgebaut werden als bisher übrigens
auch in Bundesländern im Süden unserer
Republik wo dieser Ausbau bisher stoppte
diese Bundesregierung bringt unser Land
sicherheitspolitisch auf die Höhe der
Zeit als verlässlichen Verbündeten mit
leistungsfähigen Streitkräften
nachdem Verteidigungsminister der CDU
und der CSU unsere Bundeswehr viele
Jahre vernachlässigt haben
und das Sondervermögen der Bundes für
die Bundeswehr dass wir geschaffen haben
das wird uns in die Lage versetzen einen
geordneten ein vernünftigen pfadwechsel
zu organisieren wir werden und wollen
zwei Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung für
die Bundeswehr ausgeben aber wir wollen
dafür sorgen dass die Fabriken und die
Maschinen erstmal angeschafft werden für
die Dinge die neu geschaffen werden dass
wir die richtigen Dinge bestellen und
dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Bundeswehr so ausgestattet wird dass das
über Jahrzehnte funktioniert das ist mit
dem Sondervermögen verbunden ein
langfristiger Plan nicht schneller
hektische pr-erklärung
die Bundeswehr hat es verdient dass wir
Sorgfalt walten lassen und dafür dass
wir dafür sorgen dass all die Probleme
von denen wir jetzt auch neu lernen
gelöst werden denn wir stellen ja fest
das geht dann plötzlich nicht mehr zu
sagen wir brauchen noch mal Nachschub
für die Munition weil diese Anlagen gar
nicht mehr in Betrieb sind das geht
nicht mehr wird zu sagen wir wollen von
diesem konkreten Gerät etwas haben weil
das schon seit längerem nicht mehr
produziert wird wir müssen mit dem was
wir entscheiden auch dafür sorgen dass
wir jeder Belastungssituation gerecht
werden können und auch das ist das was
wir mit dem Sondervermögen jetzt machen
es ist diese Bundesregierung der
entgegen einer jahrzehntelangen
Staatspraxis die Entscheidung getroffen
hat die Ukraine mit den Waffen zu
unterstützen die sie in einem tapferen
Verteidigungskampf Tag für Tag braucht
und dabei bleiben wir im Schulterschluss
mit unseren engsten verbündesten so
lange wie dieser sinnlose brutale
verbrecherische Krieg andauert
Russland muss endlich aufhören mit
diesem Krieg und dafür war es wichtig
dass der G20-Gipfel auf Bali einen
entsprechend deutliches Signal in
Richtung Moskau gesandt hat und noch
etwas wurde auf Bali von allen G20
Mitgliedern festgehalten jede Drohung
mit Atomwaffen ist für uns alle völlig
inakzeptabel ihr Einsatz wird nicht
hingenommen
dafür habe ich mich auch als G7
Vorsitzender eingesetzt schon auf dem
Gipfeln Elmau und ich bin froh dass
diese rote Linie auf Bali noch einmal
deutlich nachgezogen wurde auch chinas
Führung hat diese Haltung öffentlich
bekräftigt zum ersten Mal bei meinem
Besuch in Peking vor drei Wochen allein
schon deshalb hat sich der offene
Austausch mit Präsident Chi gelohnt
allein schon deswegen hat sich auch
diese Reise gelohnt gegen die Sie Herr
Merz im Vorfeld so unbedacht polymisiert
haben
und diese Bundesregierung handelt auch
im Rahmen der Europäischen Union wir
haben der Ukraine Molda und
perspektivisch auch Georgien die
Aussicht auf eine europäische Zukunft
eröffnet seit Jahren dümpelte der
Beitrittsprozess mit den
westbalkanstaaten vor sich hin jetzt
haben wir innerhalb weniger Monate
neuschwung da reingebracht
apropos Europa
es ist diese Bundesregierung die klare
Vorstellung von der Zukunft Europas
formuliert hat etwas worauf der
französische Präsident und andere
jahrelang warten mussten
mit Präsident Emmanuel macron eigentlich
das Ziel eines geopolitischen deutlich
handlungsfähigeren Europas
in Prag habe ich dazu konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht die wir nun mit
unseren Partnern vorantreiben zum
Beispiel den von Deutschland
entgegensprachten Raketen abwehr-
und Spanien haben wir erst in der
vergangenen Woche ein wichtigen Knoten
beim wichtigen strategisch ganz
zentralen Projekt für die Sicherheit und
Souveränität Europas durchschlagen wir
werden noch dieses Jahr die nächste
Phase des europäischen luftkampfsystem
fkas einleiten nachdem das Projekt hier
in Berlin lange Zeit eben nicht die
nötige politische Aufmerksamkeit
bekommen hat und zugleich haben wir ein
substanziellen
deutschen Anteil an der
Technologieentwicklung und Wertschöpfung
gesichert so sieht die Bundes die
Europapolitik dieser Bundesregierung aus
sie führt Europa zusammen und das ist
gut für unser Land
und zugleich investiert diese
Bundesregierung mit voller Kraft in
moderne Infrastrukturen Digitalisierung
damit Deutschland nicht länger das Land
der Funklöcher und der Schlaglöcher
bleibt das Land der kaputten Brücken und
der verspäteten Züge
diese Bundesregierung war es auch die im
Sommer mit dem neuen euro-ticket endlich
frischen Wind in den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr gebracht hat
und jetzt sorgen wir mit dem digitalen
deutschlandticket und mit einer
Milliarde mehr an
Regionalisierungsmitteln für einen
langfristig attraktiven ÖPNV in
Deutschland
diese Bundesregierung reformiert das
Einwanderungsrecht und sorgt für bessere
Ausbildungsangebote und
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten für
diejenigen die hierzulande leben
umso Schritt für Schritt die Lücke
Millionen fehlender Fachkräfte zu
schließen die wir geerbt haben
diese Bundesregierung räumt auf mit all
diesen Versäumnissen und das trotz
Ukraine Krieg trotz Pandemie trotz
Energiekrise trotz gestörter
Lieferketten und weltweiter Inflation
fast 100 Gesetze haben wir in unseren
ersten elf Monaten gemeinsam auf den Weg
gebracht dazu gehören einige der größten
entlastungspakete für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und Unternehmen in der
Geschichte unseres Landes dazu gehört
ein
inflationsausgleichsgesetz durch das 48
Millionen Bürgern und Bürger erheblich
weniger Steuern zahlen sie reden von
Entlastung aber stimmen ergeben wir
setzen Entlastung um
und dann höre ich dass Sie Herr Merzig
beim CDU-Parteitag hinstellen und allen
Ernstes behaupten nicht die letzten 16
Jahre CDU geführter Bundesregierung sein
das Problem unseres Landes sondern die
letzten 16 Wochen und der Führung der
amtlichen
da kann ich nur sagen wer das glaubt der
glaubt auch ansprechende weiße Kaninchen
willkommen in NSS Wunderland
willkommen im Wunderland der cdu/csu wo
die Realität auf dem Kopf steht
die Realität ist doch diese
Bundesregierung hat in zwölf Monaten
mehr in Gang gebracht umgesetzt und
aufgeräumt als in den Regierung der
vergangenen 12 Jahre möglich war
weil wir eine Regierung der Tat sind
angetreten um unser Land voranzubringen
was uns aber vor allem unterscheidet
sehr geehrter märz das ist ganz offenbar
das Bild dass wir von den Bürgern und
Bürgern unseres Landes haben
wir haben in den vergangenen Tagen
intensiv über das Bürgergeld diskutiert
und ich bin froh dass wir hierzu eine
einvernehmliche Lösung gefunden haben
eine gute Übung ist eines will ich aber
doch festhalten was wir nun zur
gesetzlichen Regel machen ist nichts
anderes als das was wir damals auch mit
der Unterstützung der Union während der
corona-pandemie richtigerweise
eingeführt haben
damals waren viele Arbeitnehmer aber
auch Selbstständige plötzlich von
staatlichen Leistungen abhängig die sich
das vorher nie hätten träumen lassen
ihnen nicht gleich alles Ersparte oder
die Wohnung zu nehmen das hat uns damals
allen eingeleuchtet
dieselbe gerechtigkeitsvorstellung
leitet auch die Reform die wir nun
beschließen werden
als vor 20 Jahren die damaligen
Arbeitsmarktreformen umgesetzt worden da
fehlte es an Arbeitsplätzen in unserem
Land heute hingegen fehlen uns
qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte deshalb sind
bessere Beratung aus und Weiterbildung
sowie weniger Bürokratie ganz
entscheidende Bestandteile unserer Form
es geht um Wege raus aus der
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit raus aus
Hilfsjobs und hinein in den Arbeitsmarkt
wenn ich mit Bürgern und Bürgern spreche
zum Beispiel bei meinen bürgerdialogen
in Magdeburg Essen Lübeck oder Gifhorn
dann sorgen sich viele nicht nur um die
hohen Preise für Energie-
das zeigt doch eines ganz klar die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen arbeiten
und sie wollen von ihrer Arbeit
anständig leben können
und darum stehen diejenigen die anpacken
die den Laden am Laufen halten die
morgens aufstehen und zur Arbeit gehen
von Beginn an im Mittelpunkt unserer
Politik
deshalb war es uns so wichtig den
Mindestlohn auf zwölf Euro anzuheben
sechs Millionen Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer bekommen dadurch mehr Lohn
und ein Handstück Anerkennung für ihre
harte Arbeit
auch höhere Mindestlohn in der
Pflegebranche und die Bezahlung von
Beschäftigten in der Altenpflege nach
regionalen Tarifverträgen sorgen für
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen und das für
eine der wohl wichtigsten und am
stärksten belasteten Berufsgruppen
unseres Landes
alle die weniger als 2.000 Euro im Monat
verdienen Zahlen ab Januar
geringere Sozialabgaben für jemanden der
bislang 1100 Euro verdient hat macht das
im Monat über 50 Euro mehr im
Portemonnaie das betrifft beschäftigt
den Teilzeit alleinerziehende Mütter und
Väter aber auch manchen Kassierer im
Supermarkt oder die Dame in der
Reinigung richtig dass wir das jetzt
machen
allein die Anhebung des Kindergeldes
einheitlich auf 250 Euro pro Kind sorgt
bei einer Familie mit zwei Kindern
kommendes Jahr für rund 750 Euro mehr im
Portemonnaie der Kinderzuschlag für
Familien mit kleineren Arbeitseinkommen
wird pro Kind dann jährlich bei bis zu
3000 Euro liegen so lösen wir die
versprechen ein dass in unserem
wohlhabenden Land kein Kind in Armut
aufwachsen muss
vor zwei Wochen haben wir die größte
wohngeldreform in der Geschichte unseres
Landes beschlossen damit steigt die Zahl
der Berechtigten ab Januar von 600.000
auf rund zwei Millionen das sorgt für
ein Plus von mehreren hundert Euro im
Monat in der Haushaltskasse und zwar
genau bei denen die hart arbeiten und
dennoch nicht viel mehr als den
Mindestlohn bekommen oder die eine
kleine Rente beziehen genauso holen wir
Leute aus der Grundsicherung die er
Leben lang hart gearbeitet haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
sorgen dafür dass Arbeit sich mehr lohnt
als zu jedem Zeitpunkt einer CDU
geführten Bundesregierung indem wir
diejenigen besser stellen die auch für
kleinere Gehälter hat arbeiten
das ist im Sinne derjenigen die arbeiten
wollen das ist im Sinne der Unternehmen
die händeringend Arbeitskräfte suchen
und das ist im Sinne unseres Landes das
gerade in dieser schwierigen Zeit mehr
Zusammenhalt braucht und weniger
zitracht
meine Damen und Herren um Zusammenhalt
geht es auch wenn wir diejenigen
entlasten die zwar ein ordentliches
Auskommen haben die aber angesichts der
Preissteigerung nun ebenfalls spitzer
rechnen müssen
Rentenbeiträge sind ab jammern nur voll
steuerlich absetzbar macht fünf
Milliarden Euro Entlastung in den
kommenden beiden Jahren
und noch etwas haben wir erreicht im
Rahmen der von uns ins Leben gerufenen
konzertierten Aktionen haben arbeitgeber
und Gewerkschaften den Weg frei gemacht
für steuerfreie Einmalzahlung von bis zu
3000 Euro jährlich zusätzlich zu den
linearen tarifverhörungen das zeigt
einmal mehr wie verantwortlich sich die
Sozialpartner in Deutschland Verhalten
und dieses Instrument wird genutzt erst
ende letzter Woche haben sich die
Tarifpartner in der
metall-zahlung von 3000 Euro geeinigt
und auch andere Branchen und Arbeitgeber
gehen den Weg über eine solchen Energie
oder inflationsbonus Banken Autobauer
und Einzelhändler die chemische
Industrie die Papier und
Zellstoffindustrie oder die Eisen und
Stahlindustrie ein großer Fortschritt
für viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
Landes die jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen
vorletzte Woche haben wir hier zu dem
das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz beschlossen
das ab Januar 48 Millionen
Steuerpflichtige entlastet
2023 reden wir über 19 Milliarden Euro
Steuerersparnis im Jahr darauf so über
32 Milliarden Euro weniger Steuern
darin enthalten sind der vollständige
Ausgleich der kalten Progression aber
auch deutlich spürbare Erhöhung des
Grundfreibetrags des Arbeitnehmer oder
des Sparer Pauschbetrages des
Kindergeldes und des Kinderzuschlags
alles das haben wir hier auf den Weg
gebracht
das ist eine klare Absage an
schleichende Steuererhöhung und die
größte Anpassung der Steuertarife
aufgrund der kalten Progression die es
in Deutschland jemals gab
die Botschaft an die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger lautet unser Staat sorgt dafür
dass Leistung sich lohnt und das
Millionen Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Deutschland aus eigener Kraft durch
diese Krise kommen kann
eine Krise von der wir heute sagen
können
unser Land hat sie im Griff
ich habe die vollen Gasspeicher erwähnt
die flüssiggast Terminals die neuen
Lieferverträge das wieder anlaufen der
Kohlekraftwerke den Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke all das bedeutet für
diesen Winter ist Deutschlands
Energiesicherheit wohl gewährt ist
sie ist gesichert weil die
Bundesregierung beherzt umgesteuert hat
und weil die Haushalte und die
Unternehmen im ganzen Land sparsam mit
Energie umgehen
das bleibt sehr wichtig gerade auch im
Blick auf das kommende Jahr und den
Winter 23
den Bürgern und Bürgern danke ich schon
jetzt von Herzen danke für so viel
Voraussicht und gemeinsam
wir können den Anstieg der Energiepreise
nicht vollständig wegzuventionieren aber
weder reduzieren Ihnen auf einen
verträgliches Maß
die Absenkung der Umsatzsteuer auf Gast
und Fernwärme von 19 auf sieben Prozent
ist beschlossene Sache die Übernahme der
Dezember Abschlagszahlung für Gas und
Wärmekunden kommt
nach intensiven Abstimmung auch mit der
Europäischen Union und den Versorgern
stehen die Rahmenbedingungen für die
gastwärme und strompreisbremsen für
Haushalte sowie für Unternehmen und da
braucht man auch nicht fragen wie es so
aussieht man kann es heute in einen
Zeitungen lesen zum ersten märz treten
sie in Kraft ausgezahlt wird dann nicht
nur eine Entlastung für den Monat März
sondern rückwirkend auch für die Monate
Januar und Februar
viele gastverbraucher haben in den
vergangenen Wochen Schreiben von ihren
Versorgern oder Vermietern mit
preisservice auf 20 30 Teil sogar 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde erhalten vorher
lagen sie oft nur bei 7 oder 8 Cent für
80% des vorjahresverbrauchs werden wir
den Preis daher bei 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde Decke
das bedeutet für viele immer noch mehr
kosten aber diese liegen erheblich unter
den neu aufgerufenen Preisen der
Versorger
ich weiß auch vermeintlich überschaubare
Erhöhungen sind gerade für die kaum zu
stemmen die ohnehin schon mit jedem Euro
rechnen müssen und deshalb stellen wir
für Härtefälle zwölf Milliarden Euro aus
dem Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds zur
Verfügung
was die Kosten für Strom Gas und Wärme
angeht so landen wir mit den
Preis
-
und Experten die Preise im Jahr 2024
sehen dann werden wir mehr Flüssigkeits
Terminals am Netz haben dann wird sich
auch der beschleunigte Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien noch stärker
bemerkbar machen und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir jetzt einmalig die
große Summe von 200 Milliarden Euro
aufbringen um die Zeit bis dahin ohne
strukturbrüche ohne
energiepreisbedingte firmenleiten und
ohne den Verlust hunderttausende
Arbeitsplätze zu überstehen
unser Land hat die Kraft diese Krise zu
meistern und gestärkt aus ihrer
vorzugehen
diese Kraft mobilisieren wir mit dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds und den
entlastungspaketen die wir bereits in
den letzten Monaten Stück für Stück
geschnürt haben
und ich danke den Wirtschaftsminister
den Finanzminister und der gesamten
Koalition für ihre Unterstützung auf
diesem Weg der Deutschland sicher durch
diese schwierige Zeit führt
die nächsten Jahre sind entscheidend um
Deutschland und Europa zu stärken für
die großen Herausforderungen wie den
Klimawandel die Digitalisierung die
Sicherung unseres Wohlstandes den
sozialen Zusammenhalt und den
demografischen Wandel wir fühlen uns
gemeinsam dem Fortschritt verpflichtet
uns eint dass wir die Chancen der
Veränderung sehen
das war ein Zitat die Sätze stehen nun
ersten sondierungspapier in dem sich die
Partner dieser Regierungskoalition vor
gut einem Jahr über ihre gemeinsamen
Ziele verständigt haben
am Anfang dieser Bundesregierung stand
das gemeinsame Bekenntnis von SPD grün
und FDP zum Fortschritt zum Aufbruch zur
zupackenden Erneuerung unseres Landes
das ist der Geist mit dem die
Bundesregierung ihre Arbeit aufgenommen
hat das ist der Geist der die
Bundesregierung weiterhin trägt
denn wenn die zeitenwände und ich bin in
dankbar Herr Merz dass sie meine Rede
noch einmal aufgegriffen haben und die
globalen Krisen um uns herum uns eines
gelehrt haben dann doch dieses unser
Land braucht Veränderung ein bloßes
weiter so ist keine
Opposition ist keine Option
ich habe sie absichtlich angeguckt die
Partei des weiters so sitzt jetzt in der
Opposition und da gehört sie auch hin
und darum ist es gut dass unser Land in
dieser Zeitenwende eine Regierung hat
die mehr will als am bestehenden
festzuhalten
wir haben von Beginn an klargemacht die
Zukunft unserer Energieversorgung gehört
Windkraft Solarenergie und grünem
Wasserstoff
damit machen wir uns nicht nur
unabhängig
von unzuverlässigen Lieferanten wie
Russland und schützen das Klima damit
bringen wir auch die Energiekosten
dauerhaft unter Kontrolle
deshalb haben wir dieses Jahr genutzt um
wichtige Gesetze zu verabschieden die
wir brauchen um den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und der
stromübertragungsnetze deutlich zu
beschleunigen
bislang lief es doch meist so vor einer
großen internationalen Klimakonferenz
oder zum Bau beginnen einer
Legislaturperiode wurde für den Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien oder für Einsparung
von Treibhausgasen ein ehrgeiziges Ziel
ausgegeben meist schön weit weg in der
Zukunft
die Schritte dorthin aber die wurden nie
wirklich konkret aus buchstabiert
auch das haben wir geändert unser Ziel
bis 2030 80 Prozent unseres Stroms aus
erneuerbaren zu erzeugen geht einher mit
einer klaren Anpassung der Ausbauziele
und Ausschreibung
im kommenden Jahr verdreifachen wir zum
Beispiel die ausschreibungsvolumiger für
Windparks an Land bei
Photovoltaikanlagen werden sie nahezu
verdoppelt der Ausbau erneuerbare
Energien
das beschleunigt Planungsverfahren
2% der Landesfläche stehen künftig für
Windkraftanlagen zur Verfügung um die
Akzeptanz bei den Bürgern und Bürgern zu
erhöhen haben wir neue
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten geschaffen die
Strom vor Ort dann auch spürbar
günstiger machen und allein mit der
Abschaffung der EEG-Umlage haben wir
nicht nur die Stromkosten
reduziert die ansonsten aufgerufen
worden wären sondern auch für eine
dringend notwendige Entbürokratisierung
des Energierechts gesorgt
nicht jede dieser Maßnahmen wirkt über
Nacht zumal viele Unternehmen in der
solar- und Windkraftbranche in den
vergangenen Jahren unter der
corona-krise aber eben auch unter
Bürokratie und unklaren Perspektiven
gelitten haben
aber es geht deutlich voran
im ersten Halbjahr 22 ist dies
Stromerzeugung aus Windkraft um etwa 18
Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr gestiegen
beim Zubau von offshore wind Energie
hatte sich seit Mitte 2020 überhaupt
nichts mehr getan bis wir im Sommer
erstmals wieder neue Anlagen Betrieb
genommen haben weitere werden folgen
im Verkehr ist der Anteil von
Biokraftstoff vom 11% und der von
strommas erneuerbaren Energien sogar am
14% gegenüber dem Vorjahr angewachsen
alles in allem hat erneuerbare Energie
im ersten Halbjahr dieses Jahres
erstmals die Hälfte des Stromverbrauchs
in Deutschland gedeckt im
Vorjahreszeitraum lagen wir noch bei 43
Prozent das zeigt die Richtung stimmt
aber natürlich brauchen wir für diese
enorme Transformation in der Industrie
im Verkehr beim Bauen und beim Wohnen
nicht nur die richtigen politischen
Rahmenbedingungen
wir brauchen das Handwerk die
Bauunternehmen die Informationstechnik
wir brauchen Arbeitnehmern und
Arbeitnehmer die Windräder aufbauen
Häuser dämmen und Wärmepumpen
installieren
deshalb fördern wir auch die berufliche
aus- und Weiterbildung deshalb bringen
wir in der Allianz für Transformation
regelmäßig Politik Unternehmen
Gewerkschaften Wissenschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft zusammen
konkret wird es beim nächsten Treffen
der Allianz im Februar um die Frage
gehen wie wir dank der herausragenden
Forschung in Deutschland die
Technologien entwickeln und in die
Breite tragen die für die Transformation
nötig sind zum Beispiel beim Wasserstoff
diese Fragen sind entscheidend und zwar
aus zwei Gründen
zum einen werden die aufstrebenden
Staaten Asiens Afrikas Lateinamerikas
und der Karibik nur dann beim
internationalen Klimaschutz mitziehen
wenn das nicht zu Lasten des Wohlstands
ihrer Bevölkerung geht
das ist bei meinen Gesprächen auf der
Klimakonferenz in Sharm el schick noch
einmal sehr deutlich geworden dafür aber
brauchen wir Technologien die
klimaneutrales Wachstum möglich machen
zum anderen liegt genau darin eine
riesige Chance für die deutsche
Industrie für unsere Maschinenbauer für
den Mittelstand mit seinen
Weltmarktführern für unsere
Autohersteller sie sind es die mit ihrer
Innovationskraft und ihren Investitionen
in Forschung und Entwicklung in der Lage
sind die nötigen Technologien
herzustellen und zu liefern die
weltweite Nachfrage danach ist schon
jetzt gewaltig
und deshalb eröffnet es uns neue
Marktchancen wenn Deutschland bis 2045
eines der ersten klimaneutralen
Industrieländer wird genau das streben
wir an und das werden wir auch schaffen
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Preis
ist nicht Tuns wäre unvergleichlich hoch
deshalb wollen wir mit den Versäumnissen
einer Energie- und Handelspolitik die
uns im einseitige Abhängigkeiten vor
allem von Russland China geführt hat auf
deshalb sorgen wir nach Jahren der
Vernachlässigung für eine moderne starke
Bundeswehr die unser Land und unsere
Alliierten verteidigen kann deshalb
beheben wir die jahrelang Versäumnisse
einer rückwärtsgewandten Verkehrspolitik
und die Defizite bei der Digitalisierung
unseres Landes
deshalb gehen wir gegen den
Fachkräftemangel vor und schaffen nach
Jahren der Blockaden ein modernes
Einwanderungsrecht
deshalb erkennen wir an
dass der Wohnungsbau eine zentrale
soziale Frage ist die nicht mehr von
einem Innen- und heimatminister nebenbei
mitverwaltet werden darf und deshalb
lösen wir all die Blockaden die Energie
und Klimawende jahrelang ausgebremst
haben
und bei all dem halten wir unser Land
zusammen und lassen niemanden zurück
es geht jetzt nicht darum sich in einem
Wunderland zu verirren die Bürgern und
Bürger müssen das ganz genau gefragt ist
harte Arbeit gefragt sind Aufbruch und
Fortschritt Zusammenhalt und die
Konzentration auf das Wesentliche dafür
steht diese Bundesregierung
ich lade Sie Herr Merz und ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herzlich ein
arbeiten Sie mit uns zusammen an der
großen Aufgabe unser Land zukunftsfest
zu machen in einer Welt tiefgreifender
Umbrüche krisenfest und winterfest ist
Deutschland schon dank der
Veränderungsbereitschaft und Tatkraft
seiner Bürgerinnen und Bürger und ja
dank der Arbeit dieser Bundesregierung
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz in der
Generaldebatte zum Bundeshaushalt 2023
vergleichsweise temperamentvoll
zumindest gibt er sich sehr
selbstbewusst und hat hier eine lange
Liste vorgetragen von dem was seiner an
sich nach die Bundesregierung schon
alles richtig gemacht hat verweist auf
rund 100 Gesetze die man verabschiedet
habe auf den erhöhten Mindestlohn
geringere Sozialabgaben für
Geringverdiener erhöhtes Kindergeld und
viele Punkte mehr am Ende der Rede ging
es dann auch noch mal um Klimaschutz und
den weltweiten Handel es gibt es viele
Applaus aus den reinen der Koalition und
wir schauen auch noch mal auf den Inhalt
der Rede weitestgehend von Polemik frei
einmal gab es das in Richtung
Opposition und Friedrich Merz das sei
jetzt die Partei des weiter so dieser
jetzt in der Opposition unter gehöre sie
auch hin sagt Olaf Scholz in Richtung
Friedrich Merz hier geht's weiter mit
Alice Weidel der Vorsitzenden in der
Fraktion der AFD
das Olaf Scholz und Friedrich Merz exakt
gleich klingt wie peinlich ist das
eigentlich man merkt dass Friedrich Merz
unbedingt Bundeskanzler werden will der
redet schon wie Olaf Scholz aber nun ja
[Applaus]
noch zwei Wochen aber dann ist die wohl
schlechteste Regierung in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein
volles Jahr im Amt bei ihnen im
Kanzleramt mögen dann die Korken knallen
für die Bürger gibt es dagegen nichts zu
feiern 12 Monate Ampel das sind 12
Monate mutwillige Zerstörung unserer
Wirtschaft und unseres Wohlstandes zwölf
Monate Gängelung Bevormundung und
Schröpfen der Bürger zwölf Monate
Politik eine Regierung die
Einschränkungen Predigt während sie
selbst aus den Vollen schöpft eine
Politik die der Regierungsapparat um
mehr als 10.000 Stellen aufbläht das
muss man sich mal vorstellen Deutschland
ist er dafür bekannt zu wenig Beamten zu
haben und sich für
400.000 Euro einen persönlichen
leibfotografen für den Vizekanzler
harbecken könnt eine Politik die sich
mitten in der Krise mit einem
gigantischen Ausbau des Kanzleramts ein
Monument des eigenen
größenwahnsätzen will viermal so groß
wie das Weiße Haus neuer Hubschrauber
Landeplatz zweite kanzlerwohnung mit 250
Quadratmetern für Kanzler Olaf und 400
neue Büroräume inklusive kosten fast 800
Millionen Euro
dekadenter geht es kaum
Täuschungen und Unwahrheiten sind die
Währung der Politik dieser Regierung
einer Politik die die auf Illusionen
Wählerbetrug und Hofberichterstattung
des öffentlichen Rundfunks gebaut ist
das wohl größte und teuerste
Lügengebäude ist die sogenannte
Energiewende sie wollen dieses
wahnsinnsexperiment am offenen Herzen
unserer Volkswirtschaft bis zum bitteren
Ende durchziehen gegen alle Gesetze der
Natur und Physik ein Industrieland mit
Gelegenheit Strom aus Sonne und Wind
betreiben dabei aus Kernkraft Kohle und
Erdöl gleichzeitig aussteigen und sich
als Backup für die fake-power aus diesen
sogenannten erneuerbaren Energien allein
auf teures Flüssiggas setzen diese
Illusion ist die Lebenslüge der
Energiewende sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
wir haben keinen Stromproblem mit dieser
dreisten Falschbehauptung hat der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister die Bürger
noch Mitte Juli hinters Licht geführt
ich weiß nicht was da passiert ist
vielleicht hat der abex so lange in der
Sonne gelegen anstatt zu arbeiten weil
ansonsten wäre mir dieser schwachsinnige
Satz überhaupt nicht rausgerutscht denn
wir haben einen Stromproblem Millionen
erfahren dieser Tage von ihren
Stromversorger dass sich der
kilowattstunden-preis deutlich mehr als
verdoppelt denn denn steigend das
Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe rechnet im Winter mit
Stromabschaltung in ganz Deutschland
eine Zumutung für die Menschen pures
Gift für die Wirtschaft und ein
Armutszeugnis für ein Industrieland
die Sprengung der nordstream-leitung war
ein nie dagewesener Angriff auf unsere
lebensnotwendige Infrastruktur
offenkundig von einem anderen Staat
Reaktion dieser Bundesregierung
dröhnendes schweigen und warum tun sie
eigentlich nichts dafür dass Russland
Erdgas durch die intakte Leitung von
nordstream 2 liefert um dem Pleite zu
Nami in der deutschen Wirtschaft zu
verhindern wer wenn irgendwann
herauskommen sollte dass der Kanzler
einen
unterschriftsreifen Vertrag auf dem
Tisch hatte um
Erdgaslieferung über nordstream 2 nach
Deutschland sicherzustellen um die Not
abzumildern wehe wenn das irgendwann mal
herauskommen sollte ihre Politik
zerstört Deutschland
Rezession und Inflation
Pullman den produktiven Mittelstand das
Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft und treiben
die bürgerliche Mittelschicht in die
Verarmung die Ursache für beides ist
nicht der Ukraine Krieg das ist eine
jämmerliche Ausrede die Ursachen sind
die von Merkel und der CDU begonnene und
die von ihnen ins Absurde
gesteigerte grüne Energiepolitik die
Energie systematisch knapp und teuer
macht die repressive corona-politik die
falsche hochsteuerpolitik die
Sanktionspolitik gegen Russland und die
Verschuldungspolitik der EU die den Euro
zu einer sterbenden
Wohlstands vernichtenden
inflationswährung gemacht hat das ist
das Ergebnis ihrer Politik
das EU-Verbot des verbrennermotors
wird den Automobilstandort Deutschland
zerstören und unsere Industrie die
Weltmarktführerschaft kosten aber sie
jubeln darüber
die Idee Industrialisierung Deutschlands
ist schon in vollem Gange die
Großkonzerne gehen ins Ausland die
Kleinbetriebe gehen pleite
und mit ihnen
gehen Hunderttausende von Arbeitsplätze
verloren
die Erzählung vom reichen Land ist ein
Lügenmärchen in Deutschland ist nur der
Fiskus reich und diese Leute dort und
macht die arbeitende Bevölkerung arm
darum geht es doch hier den flationen
lässt real Einkommen Ersparnisse und
Renten dahinschmelzen was die Leute sich
ein Leben lang harte arbeitet haben ist
bei diesen Inflationsraten nach drei bis
vier Jahren nur noch die Hälfte wert und
lassen Sie mal weitere Jahre ins Land
ziehen was da passiert aber sie denken
gar nicht daran die Gier der Steuerstaat
ist so zügeln um die Menschen zu
entlasten wer seine Lebensleistung
seinen Kindern vererben will wird
gnadenlos abkassiert von wegen mit der
FDP GWS keine Steuererhöhung und zu
allem Überfluss
verhöhnen sie die Bürger auch noch mit
teuren Steuergeld finanzierten
einfältigen Werbekampagnen dümlicher
besser
und penetranter Einmischung in die
private Lebensgestaltung die
aufdringliche corona-entfärbung eines
Lauterbach ist eine doppelte Frechheit
sie ist nicht nur miserabel gemacht sie
verbreitet auch vorsätzlich längst
widerlegte Falschbehauptung
die
[Applaus]
mRNA Impfung schützt nicht vor der
Übertragung des Virus das ist
nachgewiesen darauf war sie nie angelegt
das hat die kaisermanagerin Janine small
bereits vor Wochen in einer Anhörung des
EU-Parlaments zugegeben aber Karl
Lauterbach der Pharma Lobbyist im Gewand
des
Gesundheitsministers klammert sich
weiter an die impflüge auf deren
Grundlage Millionen Menschen unter Druck
gesetzt und ungeimpfte unerträglich
diffamiert wurden das totalitäre
Experiment ihrer corona-politik die
unsere Gesellschaft schwer beschädigt
hat muss ein Ende haben und
aufgearbeitet werden
dann musst du auf die zweifelhafte Rolle
vieler Medien auf den Tisch die nicht
nur in der corona-krise als Kontrolleure
der mächtigen versagt haben die Ausfälle
eines öffentlich rechtlichen
fernsehproleten der im Zusammenhang mit
dem Virus Kinder als Ratten und Pest
über Träger bezeichnete sind ein
bitterer Tiefpunkt finanziert über
Zwangsgebühren wie erbärmlich und dann
noch dieses hirnrissige gendere
einfach nur noch bekloppt was hier
abgeliefert werden darum fordern wir
seit Jahren die Abschaffung der GEZ
Zwangsgebühren es ist unerträglich
Medien
die schließlich als hofschranken der
Regierung betätigen statt frische
kritische Fragen zu stellen sind Teil
des Problems einer maßlosen
corona-politik genauso wie das
irrationalen klimawands und der völlig
aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
Migrationspolitik der offenen Grenzen
deutschland hat in diesem Jahr schon
mehr Migranten aufgenommen als auf dem
Höhepunkt der asylkrise 2015/16 die
Kommunen sind hoffnungslos überlastet
und sie nehmen den Kontrollverlust nicht
nur hin sie heizen die Migranten Sturm
auch noch an sie schließen
Sonderabkommen zum Import von 10.000 in
Afghanen sie verteilen Millionen an
Schleuser darunter auch die Organisation
von dem Partner von Frau Göring-Eckardt
das muss man sich mal vorstellen und Sie
schaffen mit dem Umbau
das hartz-iv-systems zum Bürgergeld
einen mächtigen
migrationsmagneten der asylzuwanderer
mit den höchsten Sozialleistungen aller
EU-Staaten lockt wer ist nach
Deutschland schafft muss faktisch nicht
mehr gehen und hat über kurz oder lang
Anspruch auf volle Sozialleistung und
allen Bürgerinnen das hat mit einer
verantwortungsvollen
einwanderungs- und Asylpolitik wirklich
gar nichts mehr zu tun
die deutschen zahlen die höchsten
Steuern und Abgaben aller
Industrieländer am bekommen dafür ein
dysfunktionalen Staat verwahrloste bei
kanalisierte Innenstädte verfallende
Infrastruktur
heruntergekommene Schulen und ein
parasitäres Sozialsystem und ausufernde
Ausländerkriminalität das ist das
Ergebnis ihrer Politik und sie verteilen
überall die Steuergelder hin während die
eigenen Landsleute nach der
Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal auch nach
einem Jahr noch auf dem Trümmern ihrer
Existenz sitzen wie beschämend helfen
sie endlich diesen Menschen den Flut
Opfern und hören Sie auf die Bürger
auszunehmen anzulügen und für dumm zu
verkaufen
alles Weidel afd-fraktion
und die nächste Rednerin in dieser
Debatte zum
kanzleretat zum Etat des Kanzleramts und
des Bundeskanzlers ist jetzt die nächste
Rednerin Katharina dröge die Vorsätze
Vorsitzende der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
[Applaus]
Frau Weidel ihre Rede ist so würge endet
und das ist schon ein Grundstück bei
einer Rede die so eiskalt und widerlich
warm das selbst ihre eigene Fraktion
vergessen hat zu klatschen weil sie
erstaunt war dass das Ende war
frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen viele
Menschen haben am vergangenen Wochenende
mit Sorge auf das geschaut was bei der
Klimakonferenz in Ägypten verhandelt
wurde weil das so wichtig war was dort
verhandelt wurde weil so sichtbar ist
was die Klimakrise schon heute bedeutet
die schweren Überschwemmungen Tag ist
dann die Hitze Trockenheit und
Wassermangel in Europa man kann aktuell
auf eine Insel im Gardasee zu Fuß laufen
und auch hier in Deutschland und Frau
Weidel wenn sie über das Aartal reden
und nicht über die Klimakrise dann haben
sie das Thema einfach nicht verstanden
hier in Deutschland werden viele
Menschen in diesem Winter ein zweites
Weihnachten feiern ohne Menschen die sie
in der flutnacht verloren haben Menschen
die einen zweiten Winter in kaputten
Häusern verbringen werden ohne Heizung
Hoteliers die keine Gäste haben weil
ihre Hotels weiterhin Baustellen sind
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
können solche Orte wieder aufbauen wir
können den Hochwasserschutz verbessern
wir können unsere
katastrophen-warnsysteme moderner machen
wir können Löschflugzeuge kaufen für die
Waldbrände die künftig kommen aber wir
können nicht mehr verhindern dass solche
Katastrophen mehr werden dass das öfter
passiert das ist die Vergangenheit das
sind die Fehler die schon gemacht wurden
was allerdings vor uns liegt das ist die
Zukunft und wir werden in diesem
Jahrzehnt darüber entscheiden welche
Zukunft das wird diese Regierung hat zu
ihrem Grundsatz gemacht dass jedes
zehnte Grad Erderwärmung was wir weniger
schaffen werden einen großen Unterschied
macht daran richten wir unsere Politik
aus
und deshalb war es auch so wichtig was
bei der Klimakonferenz verhandelt wurde
deswegen wäre es auch so wichtig gewesen
wenn die Weltgemeinschaft sich auf mehr
Ambitionen verständigt hätte dass das
nicht passiert ist das ist ein
Riesenproblem umso wichtiger ist es dass
wir hier in Deutschland eine
Bundesregierung haben die gemeinsam nach
Ägypten gefahren ist mit mehreren
Ministerinnen und mit dem Kanzler die
gekämpft hat dafür dass eine dagegen
gekämpft hat dass eine fossile Allianz
aus Ländern wie Saudi-Arabien bis China
versucht hat das wichtige 1,5 Grad Ziel
wieder zurückzudrehen und die auch dafür
gekämpft hat und das war ein besonderer
Erfolg unserer Außenministerin Anna Lena
bärburg das ist endlich eine
Vereinbarung für Laus und damage gibt
anzuerkennen das ist eine historische
Verantwortung der Industrieländer gibt
für die Klimakrise die jetzt schon
existiert und dass wir deshalb eine
Verantwortung auch haben für die
finanziellen Schäden gerade in den
Ländern die am härtesten betroffen sind
und die sich am wenigsten dabei helfen
können das ist ein historischer Erfolg
und weil in Ägypten so wenig passiert
ist ist es umso wichtiger dass wir eine
Regierung haben und eine Koalition die
gerade hier zu Hause entschlossen voran
geht in Sachen Klimaschutz sie der Welt
zeigt dass gerade ein Industrieland wie
Deutschland ins gelingen kommen kann mit
Blick auf die Klimakrise mit gelingen
kommen kann nach zwei Jahrzehnten von
Stillstand die die Union in dieser Sache
verantwortlich hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter
uns liegt ein Jahr das aufgrund
vielfältiger Krisen schwerer geworden
ist als wir uns das alle gewünscht haben
und gerade deshalb ist es so eine
besondere Leistung dass wir mit Blick
auf den Klimaschutz weitergekommen sind
als viele es wahrscheinlich für
Möglichkeiten hätten wir werden das
Tempo beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien verdreifachen wir werden
endlich alle Hürden und Hindernisse aus
dem Weg räumen die sie in den
vergangenen Jahren aufgebaut haben
Deutschland war mal das Land dass die
Energiewende erfunden hat und sie von
der Union haben viel dafür getan dass
das in der Vergessenheit geraten ist der
windausbau ist nach 2017 so heftig
eingebrochen dass die Wind
Energiebranche sogar einen Namen dafür
hat und das heißt die altmaierdelle
damit machen wir jetzt Schluss
und wir haben es geschafft in einem Jahr
das so geprägt war von den fossilen
Energien in diesem Jahr haben wir es
geschafft den Kohleausstieg in
Westdeutschland um acht Jahre
vorzuziehen zwei Jahre nachdem der
Deutsche Bundestag jemals überhaupt ein
Kohleausstieg beschlossen hat und ich
bin Kölnerin das rheinische Revier das
liegt bei mir vor der Haustür und wer
jemals eine an einer Kante eines
braunkohletag war es bestanden hat wer
den Irrsinn der Zerstörung gesehen hat
den diese gigantischen Löcher
verursachen Löcher die einfach alles
fressen Häuser Bäume Kirchen Straßen der
mit Menschen reden musste und denen
erklären musste das ist irgendwen gibt
in diesem Land der ist für eine gute
Idee halt die Heimat dieser Menschen
dort wo ihre Eltern und Großeltern
aufgewachsen sind einfach fressen zu
lassen von einem Loch der weiß wie
wichtig das ist was wir hier in diesem
Jahr erreicht haben
und wir gehen in diesem Jahr noch weiter
voran wir haben den Ausstieg aus dem
Verbrennungsmotor beschlossen wir haben
den schlafenden Riesen der
Energieeffizienz geweckt die Gasheizung
werden ab dem nächsten Jahr nicht mehr
neu eingebaut wir werden als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland aus der
Energie-
wir haben mit dem 49 euro-ticket ein
Ticket geschaffen dass das Tarifsystem
für Busse und Bahnen revolutioniert ein
Ticket für ganz Deutschland deutlich
billiger als nahezu jedes Ticket was man
als Monatsticket in diesem Land kaufen
konnte was für ein riesen Schritt wer
hätte vor einem Jahr gedacht dass so
etwas in so kurzer Zeit möglich gewesen
wäre
reicht das alles
natürlich nicht wer die Klimakrise ernst
nimmt der weiß dass wir uns deutlich
mehr werden anstrengen müssen im
Verkehrssektor alleine das sagen die
Sachverständigen der Bundesregierung
werden wir das Tempo für 14-fachen
müssen wir werden den Kohleausstieg im
Osten umsetzen müssen wir werden eine
solarpflicht auf allen Dächern einführen
um nur einige Beispiele zu nennen aber
wenn man in einem einzigen Jahr so viel
schafft trotz Krise dann ist das ein
Versprechen an die Zukunft dann ist das
ein Versprechen dafür was gelingen kann
wenn man es nur will ich stehe hier vor
Ihnen als Vorsitzende einer
Regierungsfraktion die mit all ihren
Abgeordneten mit jedem einzelnen von uns
mit all unseren Ministern und
insbesondere ganz voran mit Robert
Habeck jeden Tag daran arbeitet das aus
dem müssen einen machen wird
machen wird das ist unsere Haltung und
wenn ich in ihre Richtung Blicke von der
Union dann sehe ich das Gegenteil sie
standen in den letzten 16 Jahren für
zöder zögern Zaudern und Bremsen Herr
Merz sie haben von dem Thema
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit eben gesprochen und
ich sage Ihnen sie hätten aus
Deutschland lieber ein Industriemuseum
gemacht als sich zu trauen auf das Thema
Innovation zu setzen und mit der
Elektromobilität endlich mal einen
Schritt in die Zukunft zu geben sie
haben uns so lange die Geschichte davon
erzählt dass es zu Kohle Öl und Gas
keine Alternative in der Industrie gibt
dass sie das wahrscheinlich immer noch
gemacht hätten selbst wenn die ganze
Welt schon auf grünem Wasserstoff
gesetzt hätte und sie haben so lange ein
modernes Einwanderungsgesetz blockiert
bis in der Wirtschaft überall Fachkräfte
fehlen das ist die Wirtschaftspolitik
der Union
und mit Blick auf China sie haben eben
auch von China gesprochen wenn ich mir
anschaue was sie in den letzten 16
Jahren mit Blick auf China gemacht haben
dann war das eine Politik die vor allen
Dingen darauf gesetzt hat wir schauen
nicht hin wir hoffen dass
handelwandelerzeug wir tun zwar nichts
dafür wir gehen immer weiter voran in
die falsche Richtung und wir schauen weg
und ich sage Ihnen so funktioniert das
nicht so funktioniert das wieder
wirtschaftlich mit China was die
deutsche Industrie zum Glück auch
mittlerweile erkannt hat und so
funktioniert das auch nicht mit Blick
auf unsere Werte gerade mit einem
autoritären staatlich China braucht ist
das Thema Menschenrechte gerade dann ist
es wichtig auf starke
lieferkettengesetze zu setzen auf das
Verbot von Zwangsarbeit zu setzen und
nicht einfach ein Investitionsabkommen
mit China weiter voranzutreiben die
Angela Merkel dass die ganze Zeit wollte
Werte und Haltung Menschenrechte spielen
nicht nur in der Außenpolitik eine Rolle
spielen nicht nur im Sport eine Rolle
sie spielen auch in der Wirtschaft eine
Rolle
und dann komme ich zum Thema Klimaschutz
während die Welt nach Ägypten geschaut
hat hat man von ihnen Herr Merz herzlich
wenig dazu gehört ich habe mich gefragt
war ihnen das eigentlich wirklich so
egal was sie da verhandelt haben oder
passte es einfach nur nicht in ihr
Konzept das markanteste was man am
vergangenen Wochenende während die Welt
in Ägypten verhandelt hat nämlich gehört
hat das waren die Aussagen ihres Vizes
Jens Spahn der sich nicht zu schade war
auf einem Parteitag der Union vor dem
Entstehen einer klimaddiktatur zu waren
nur weil ihm das Buch einer
tatsjournalistin nicht gefallen hat
klimadiktatur ernsthaft ich frage mich
wirklich wo will die Union eigentlich
gerade hin so ein framing so eine
Zuspitzung so über eine überdrehte
Polemik hat man bislang in den Debatten
nur von der AFD gehört und ich sage
Ihnen sie tragen auch als Opposition
eine
Verantwortung für die Diskussion die wir
hier führen wenn Sie Herr Merz bei der
Aufnahme von ukrainischen geflüchteten
von sozialtourismus sprechen was vorher
nur in rechten Blogs und wird russischer
Propaganda aufgeschrieben wurde und wenn
Sie das über wiederholen und dann Thema
Sozialleistungen von poleffekten und
falschen Anreizen sprechen dann macht
das was mit diesem Land dann vergiften
Sie unsere politische Debatte dann
spaltet das da wo Politik eigentlich
Wege suchen sollte um zu verbinden und
dann macht das ganz besonders was mit
dem Leben der Menschen die hier
hinkommen und Schutz suchen für die wird
dieses Leben dann deutlich schwerer
und ich hoffe ganz ehrlich
dass die Union diesen Weg nicht
weitergeht denn ein Land das in einer
Krise ist der größten Krise in Europa
seit vielen vielen Jahren der größten
Energiekrise der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland der braucht beides Regierung
und Opposition wir brauchen eine Haltung
dass Sie und wir Verantwortung
übernehmen Verantwortung dafür dass wir
zusammen durch diese Krise kommen gerade
weil wir die Ukraine in diesem Winter
der so hart und kalt wird wo Russland
auf die Infrastruktur geht wenn wir die
Ukraine mehr unterstützen müssen braucht
es Zusammenhalt statt Spaltung auch in
den deutschen Debatten
und wenn wir die Menschen in diesem Land
bei der extremen Inflation bei krassen
Preissteigerung unterstützen müssen auch
dann braucht es Zusammenhalt statt
Spaltung wir als Regierung und als
Regierungsfraktion tun alles dafür um
diese Entlastung auf den Weg zu bringen
vier entlastungspakete 300 Milliarden
Euro das ist unsere Antwort auf diese
Krise gewesen und wir haben insbesondere
die Menschen dabei in den Blick genommen
die die Unterstützung am meisten
brauchten durch die Erhöhung des
wohngelds durch den Kinderzuschlag durch
eine Erhöhung des Kindergeldes ist 49
Euro Tickets und auch die
energiepauschalen das sind unsere
Antworten und deshalb ist auch das
Bürgergeld so wichtig das die Regelsätze
nun hoffentlich wenn heute Abend der
Vermittlungsausschuss zusammenkommt um
mehr als 50 € steigen das ist ein Gebot
des Anstands sie Kölner Tafeln die haben
mir vor kurzem erzählt dass sie bei der
Essensausgabe momentan nach 20 Minuten
schließen müssen so groß ist der Andrang
dann ist das Reisen Weg das haben die
noch nie erlebt da kommen Menschen die
noch nie in ihrem Leben vorher bei den
Tafeln waren und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir heute Abend hier
endlich handeln
ich freue mich wenn sie von der Union da
heute abend zustimmen aber ihre Kampagne
dafür dass sie sagen Arbeit lohnt sich
nicht mehr in diesem Land die hätten sie
sich wirklich sparen können denn das
trägt auch wieder nur dazu bei das Land
zu spalten und wenn Sie es ernst meinen
würden damit die Interessen derjenigen
zu vertreten die geringe Einkommen haben
warum machen Sie die Kampagne dann
eigentlich immer falsch rum den Menschen
die wenig Einkommen haben den nützt uns
doch nichts dass diejenigen die noch
weniger haben weniger bekommen den würde
es doch etwas helfen wenn man ihre
Einkommenssituation verbessert was ist
denn das für eine Logik
ich freue mich wenn wir es heute Abend
schaffen sollten ein Bürgergeld zu
beschließen dass mehr ist als eine
Regelsatzerhöhung das den
vermittlungsvorgang abschafft das
hinzuverdienstregeln verbessert das
weiterbildungsstärkt das mehr auf
Kooperation und Vertrauen setzt und auf
weniger Sanktionen ich sage Ihnen ganz
ehrlich gerade in einer Krise
entscheidet sich eine politische Haltung
daran wie man mit denjenigen umgeht die
am meisten Unterstützung brauchen das
sind die Menschen die zu uns liegen das
sind die Menschen die keine Arbeit
gefunden haben ich bin froh einer
Koalition anzugehören die sich als
Haltung für Respekt würde und
Solidarität entschieden hat
offensichtlich ganz im Gegenteil zu üben
Katharina dröge ist Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und hat
hier deutliche Angriffe auf für die
Union und gerichtet und dazu diversen
Äußerungen zum Thema Klimaschutz
Flüchtlingen aus der Ukraine und Bürger
Geld sich positioniert ansonsten
erwartungsgemäß natürlich die
Schwerpunkte Klimaschutz und erneuerbare
Energien im Mittelpunkt Katharina dröge
war übrigens vor wenigen Tagen Gast in
unsere Podcast unter drei können Sie
noch gut reinhören und die immer batter
jetzt am Po ist war auch schon mal da
ist nur ein bisschen länger her
drei Viertel der BundesbürgerInnen und
Bundesbürger sind laut Deutschlandtrend
unzufrieden mit ihrer Regierung ist auch
kein Wunder selten haben so viele
Menschen in so kurzer Zeit so viel ihres
bescheidenen Wohlstands verloren wie
unter ihnen sie wollten
fortschrittskoalition sein nun hatten
sie ein Jahr lang Zeit in ihrem ersten
ampelhaushalt genau das abzubilden und
ich kann feststellen oder muss
feststellen es ist kaum eine Spur von
mehr Fortschritt und eins hat die
heutige Debatte deutlich gezeigt nur
ihre selbst Zufriedenheit kann die
Unzufriedenheit im Land noch toppen
meine Damen und Herren
ihre mangelnde Fähigkeit die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger vor der Preisexplosion
zumindest etwas zu schützen am Beispiel
der Gaspreise deutlich machen erst
wollten sie gar keine gaspreisbremse
sondern eine gasumlage also noch höhere
Preise dann eine Bremse nach dem Winter
also März jetzt im Januar was für ein
Chaos das versteht kein Abgeordnete mehr
geschweige denn die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und wie soll dann ein Betrieb mit
dieser Herangehensweise seine Zukunft
planen lieber Bundeskanzler sie leiden
kein Kabinett das solide arbeitet
sondern da sind einige diletten am Start
oder richtiger gesagt dilettantinnen und
diletten am Start heute
heute heute verzweifeln viele Menschen
an ihren Rechnungen heute wandern Firmen
ab oder melden Insolvenz an spätestens
zu Beginn der Heizperiode hätten sie
einen gaspreisdeckel ein ölpreisdeckel
geben müssen wir haben das hier im
Haushalt Monaten gefordert die
dezemberhilfe soll die gastkunden jetzt
irgendwann mit der nächsten
Jahresabrechnung erreichen jetzt und
nicht irgendwann brauchen die Menschen
Unterstützung für die Sicken
und das Rotor noch die strompreisbände
Bremse Monate später zu kommen meine
Güte ihre Politik hat mehr Verspätung
als die Deutsche Bahn meine Damen und
Herren
aber sie sind nicht nur die zu
spätkoalition sondern sie sind auch die
zu wenig Koalition ein Deckel für 12 von
12 Cent für Gas mein damit ist der
Gaspreis noch immer doppelt so hoch wie
vor dem furchtbaren Krieg Putins das ist
die Wahrheit oder 40 Cent für Strom das
sind auch 12 Cent mehr pro
Kilowattstunde das sind alles Deckelchen
beides ist viel zu hoch und vor allen
Dingen meine Damen und Herren sind ihre
Bremsen auch noch zutiefst sozial
ungerecht und ich will ihnen das auch
erklären der willenbesitzer der
profitiert am meisten je höher der
verbraucht 2022 war desto höher ist die
Entlastung 20 23 das ist doch ungerecht
sie entlasten gut Verdiener deutlich
mehr als Geringverdiener und die Mitte
der schon gespart hat der guckt den dumm
aus der Wäsche meine Damen und Herren
warum gibt es denn kein festes
bürgerkontingent für Strom und Gas pro
Person pro Haus pro Familie korrigieren
Sie diese Ungerechtigkeit meine Damen
und Herren viele Bürger lassen nicht
allein nein sie lassen sie allein und im
übrigen auch hier zeigt Österreich wie
man es richtig macht in Österreich
werden die Strompreise bei 10 Cent
gedeckelt wir haben weiterhin die
höchsten Strompreise in Europa und das
ist verheerend für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und für die Betriebe ihre Politik
macht aus der Industrienation eine
kerzenrepublik und das ist inakzeptabel
meine Damen und Herren
und dazu geht bei ihnen noch das Prinzip
jeder Versorger kann abkassieren wie er
will ob die Preise nun 20 und 30 und 40
Cent steigen ob sie verdoppelt werden
oder verdreifer alles ist möglich und im
Übrigen findet leider auch alles aktuell
statt und damit muss Schluss sein Herr
Habeck Versorger sollten sich ihre
Tarife genehmigen lassen müssen wir
brauchen staatliche Preiskontrollen in
Deutschland beenden Sie den Wilden
Westen bei denen auf dem Energiemarkt
der die Menschen ruiniert meine Damen
und Herren
oder die Spritpreise da wollten sie das
Bundeskartellamt scharf stellen sie
haben gesagt mit Klauen und Zähnen
herabag und was ist die Wahrheit ein
Miezekätzchen ist die Wahrheit das ist
korrekt die
Ölmultis die verdienen sich dumm und
dämlich 38 Milliarden Euro übergewinne
in diesem Jahr wann holen Sie das Geld
zurück dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
aus der Tasche gezogen worden ist
reales ist doch so je mehr stellen und
total an der Preisschraube den desto
mehr verdient auch der Finanzminister
über die Mehrwertsteuer das gleiche gilt
im übrigen auch in der Supermarktkasse
teurere Lebensmittel teure Energien
desto höher sind die Steuereinnahmen die
Wahrheit ist 50 Milliarden Euro mehr in
diesem Jahr und da frage ich Sie was ist
denn eigentlich mit der übergewinnsteuer
also die sie ja zufallsgewinnsteuer
nennen also als Marktwirtschaftler
überzeugt mich das nicht aber wann
schöpfen sie die Zufalls Gewinne bei den
Profiteuren der Krise denn mal ab auch
hier gilt sie kommen zu spät und jetzt
wollen sie die zufallsgewinne nicht mehr
rückwirkend ab März 2022 sondern erst ab
November 2022 abschöpfen nach
Donnerwetter Energiekonzern müsste man
sein das wäre wunderbar meine Damen und
Herren wir befinden uns real,-
[Applaus]
Koalition warum haben Sie denn beim
Bürgergeld und beim Wohngeld das nicht
schon im Sommer auf den Weg gebracht
erst im November fünf vor zwölf das hat
doch der Union dass die Möglichkeit
gegeben und eins muss ich jetzt wirklich
mal sagen Herr Scholz sie sagen hier
kein Kind in Armut sie haben die
Grundsicherung verschoben nach einem
Jahr Olaf Scholz ist die Armutsrate bei
Kindern bei über 20 Prozent dass ein
Höchstwert da können sie ja doch nicht
sagen wir lassen kein Kind zurück und
genauso ähnlich ist es auch bei den
Bürgergeld ja der Entwurf da habe ich
hier auch im Plenum einiges gelobt das
ist eine Verbesserung aber was sie jetzt
als Kompromiss haben das ist ausgetragen
auf dem Rücken der Betroffenen und
deswegen kritisieren wir das auch in
Deutlichkeit diesen Kompromiss meine
Damen und Herren
und jetzt so eine Bemerkung zu
Schuldenbremse also der Finanzminister
hat jetzt seine Schuldenbremse bekommen
die Schuldenbremse ist ja für die FDP
wie der Schnuller für das Baby wenn das
money wegnimmt dann ist das Geschrei
riesig groß aber meine Damen und Herren
die Neuverschuldung beträgt trotzdem
45,6 Milliarden Euro und Herr
Finanzminister diese Verschuldung ist
wirklich eine blanke Lügengeschichte und
das wissen sie in jedem Betrieb wäre das
Bilanzfälschung meine Damen und Herren
ein solches Vorgehen hat mit Haushalts
Klarheit und haushaltswahrheit aber auch
wirklich gar nicht zu tun sie haben
Schattenhaushalte in Größenordnung
errichtet um die Schuldenbremse
einhalten zu können sonderschulden für
das Sondervermögen ich meine
Sondervermögen bei 100 Milliarden das
ist kreditfinanziert am Haushalt
letztlich vorbei für die Aufrüstung der
Bundeswehr das sind Schulden und nichts
anderes und die 200 Milliarden die ja
grundsätzlich richtig sind die zur
Senkung der Energiepreise also
Wirtschaft Stabilisierung davon die sind
auch nur kreditfinanziert meine Damen
und Herren das hat mit solider
Haushaltspolitik nicht zu tun ihr
Haushalt ist ein Verschiebebahnhof mit
ungedeckten Checks meine Damen und
Herren
und die Bürger die an im übrigen dass
sie diese Schattenhaushalte bezahlen
müssen und ich will ihnen sagen die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben doch einen
Gegenvorschlag gemacht angesichts der
historischen Krise haben sie gefordert
und zwar völlig zu Recht höhere Steuern
für Topverdiener und Superreiche immer
die Wirtschaftsweisen das sind ihre
eigenen Sachverständigen deren
Sachverstand sie ja offensichtlich
anzweifeln und das obwohl wir in diesem
Jahr mehr Millionäre im Land haben als
je zuvor 1,6 Millionen Vermögens
Millionäre in Deutschland ich meine in
Gutachten der Wirtschaftsweisen heißt es
die Energiekrise solidarisch bewältigen
und das sind zwei zentrale Punkte die
sagen erstens ärmere Haushalte leiden
deutlich mehr unter der Inflation und
zweitens wir brauchen höhere Steuern für
Reiche und mehr Gerechtigkeit um die
Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten ja wir
brauchen endlich eine Vermögensabgabe
für Milliardäre und Multimillionäre es
geht übrigens nicht darum per
Finanzminister die Steuern zu erhöhen
nein das wollen wir überhaupt nicht wir
wollen sogar Entlastung bei den kleinen
und mittleren Einkommen auch bei
Mittelstand aber sie schützen die
Milliardäre und die Superreichen und das
ist inakzeptabel es kann doch nicht sein
es kann doch nicht sein dass in der
Krise in der Krise die Dax Vorstände
trotz bevorstehender Rezession 25
Prozent mehr Gehalt haben ein
gehaltsfluss von 25%, und hier ist es
eben schon gesagt worden bei der Tafel
gibt es 100% mehr Kundschaft das ist die
Wahrheit und das ist doch nicht normal
meine Damen und Herren da muss doch
politisch gehandelt werden das Land ist
eben nicht gut gerüstet für den Winter
es droht eine verarmungslawine über
Deutschland zu wollen und dann sagen sie
gestern sehr geehrter Finanzminister wir
haben breitflächig entlastet das waren
ihre Worte ehrlich gesagt was ist denn
das für eine Realitätsverweigerung ja
ich weiß es gab entlastungs-
aber viel zu wenig ist bei den Menschen
angekommen die wirklich die Entlastung
so dringend brauchen meine Damen und
Herren es ist doch so dass viele
Menschen viele Menschen Verständnis
hätten für eine Zeit die wegen des
furchtbaren Kriegs Putins und der Krise
schwieriger ist als zuvor aber viele
Menschen fühlen sich eben nicht
beschützt und unterstützt von ihrer
Regierung die fühlen sich schlicht
ausgeliefert sie haben das Gefühl dass
sie die Folgen von Krieg und Krise
allein tragen müssen dass sie die
Zeitenwende bezahlen müssen und das ist
doch inakzeptabel es reicht nicht
es reicht nicht Blackouts und ein
Zusammenbruch der Gasversorgung zu
verhindern
sozialwirtschaftlich und auch politisch
steht dieses Land vielleicht vor dem
schwierigsten Jahr in der Nachkriegszeit
und schauen Sie auf die Herbstprognose
der EU-Kommission
0,3% Wachstum für die gesamte EU und in
Deutschland minus 0,6 ehrlich gesagt in
keinem anderen Land ist die Prognose so
schlecht da muss man doch vielleicht
Schlussfolgerung ziehen mit dem Haushalt
2023 hätten sie einen großen
Schutzschirm über Deutschland spannen
müssen ein Schutzschirm für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und für die
Unternehmen gegen Inflation gegen
Insolvenzen und gegenverarmut aber ihr
Haushalt ist kein Schutzschirm kein you
never walk alone ihr Geist spiegelt sich
in diesem Haushalt eben nicht wieder ihr
Haushalt das ist Wellness für die
wohlhabenden und unterlassene
Hilfeleistung für die Mehrheit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes vor
allen Dingen aber ist er zutiefst
unehrlich herzlichen Dank
und das wird der Satz sein der ist dann
heute Abend in die Tagesschau und den
die Tagesthemen ins heute journal und
andere Sendungen schaffte Wellness für
die Wohlhabenden sei der Haushalt 2023
kritisierte dietmarat der Vorsitzende
der Linksfraktion und jetzt ist
Christian Dörr auf dem Weg zum Polt
Vorsitzender der FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kollegen und Kollegen das erste Jahr
dieser Koalition fällt in eine Zeit von
Krise und wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheit
die entschlossenes Handeln verlangt der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
ist der Auslöser für hohe Energiepreise
und für die wirtschaftliche Unsicherheit
in unserem Land die so niemand
vorhersehen konnte aber der Grund liegt
woanders der Grund liegt auch in
falschen Entscheidungen in der
Vergangenheit die in Deutschland
getroffen worden sind und mutmaßlich ist
von den demokratischen Fraktionen hier
im Haus da niemand frei von Schuld sind
falsche Entscheidungen in der
Vergangenheit getroffen worden die diese
Bundesregierung jetzt korrigieren muss
und korrigieren will und ich will eines
vorweg sagen insbesondere vor dem
Hintergrund des Themas Energiepreise
diese wurden Energiepreise kann sich
niemand leisten und mit diesen Preisen
darf deshalb in Deutschland niemand
alleine gelassen werden
wir haben
mit drei entlastungspaketen die privaten
Haushalte die VerbraucherInnen
Verbraucher die Unternehmen stark
entlastet und insbesondere bei der
Energiepolitik ich sprach es gerade an
haben wir neue Entscheidungen getroffen
ich will das in Richtung der Kollegen
Kollegen der Union sagen mit den
lng-terminals und jetzt mit der
Eröffnung des Terminals in Wilhelmshaven
hat in neun Monaten diese Koalition mehr
zur energiediversität mehr zu
Energiesicherheit in Deutschland
beigetragen als diese Bundesregierung in
16 Jahren unter der cdu/csu das muss man
feststellen mutige Entscheidungen in den
ersten Monaten hätte uns wahrscheinlich
damals keiner zugetraut und ganz gezielt
mit dem Abwehrschirm stabilisieren wir
den Energiepreise in Deutschland über
die gaspreisbremse und die
strompreisbremse das haben wir bereits
durch den Deutschen Bundestag gebracht
wir stellen uns dieser Krise
entschlossen entgegen wir wollen sie
bewältigen auch wenn richtig ist dass
der Staat nicht alles leisten kann aber
diese Bundesregierung tut alles was
möglich ist in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
für die Unternehmen und die Menschen in
Deutschland liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und gerade vor diesem Hintergrund ist es
umso bemerkenswerter was dieser
Bundesregierung dieser
mehrheitskoalition im Deutschen
Bundestag mit dem Bundeshaushalt 2023
gelingt wir lösen das Versprechen des
Koalitionsvertrages ein und kehren in
Deutschland endlich zur Schuldenbremse
zurück das ist ein wichtiges Zeichen für
die Stabilität Deutschlands und
Deutschlands in der Europäischen Union
liebe Kolleginnen und
ich fand an der Stelle aber sie haben es
in der Rede nicht untergemacht Herr
Merkel aber die Haltung der Union
bemerkenswert sie machen ja dieser Tage
dieser Tage viele Termine vor Ort
schließt das in der Zeitung viele
Termine mit
Bäckereien beispielsweise mit
handwerksmeisteristern es ist Herr März
umso bemerkenswerter umso
bemerkenswerter dass die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion den
Abwehrschirm für die Wirtschaft für die
privaten Haushalte in Deutschland nicht
mit Trick sondern dagegen gestimmt hat
liebe Kollegen sie haben dagegen
gestimmt
und es bleibt ihr politisches Geheimnis
wie sie die Forderung selbst aufgebracht
haben hier in Reden beispielsweise haben
sie ein gaspreisdeckel gefordert in
reden hier vorne lieber Kollege Merz
aber im Deutschen Bundestag haben sie
sich dagegen entschieden und jetzt kommt
das Argument ich will das Aufgreifen
weil sie ist nicht mehr trauen sich ist
hier vorzubringen Herr Kollege sie haben
gesagt das müssen über den
Bundeshaushalt finanzieren wer das über
den Kernhaushalt 2023 ich habe mir die
Mühe gemacht die Änderungsanträge der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion dazu
anzuschauen habe sie durchgeschaut und
sein Abwehrschirm für die Wirtschaft für
eine Finanzierung der Gas und
strompreisbremse steht in den Entwürfen
der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion exakt gar
nichts liebe Kolleginnen nach gar nichts
schlagen Sie an dieser Stelle vor
ja
diese Koalition hat den Beschluss der
alten Bundesregierung für den Haushalt
22 für den abgelaufenen Haushalt jetzt
die Schuldenbremse auszusetzen
aufgegriffen und fortgesetzt auch um
diesen Abwehrschirm insbesondere zu
finanzieren aber ich finde es
bemerkenswert dass gerade sie gerade Sie
diese ja in Karlsruhe dagegen klagen
Mittel aus dem Klima und
transformationspunkt zu nutzen in ihren
Änderungsantrag drin zum Bundeshaushalt
genau diese Mittel einsetzen wie logisch
ist das denn noch dass wir uns für nie
liebe Kollegen da sind sehr gespaltene
Persönlichkeit deshalb wird
und ich sage haushaltspolitisch auch wie
viel besser wäre es gewesen wenn zur
Zeiten der corona-krise die große
Koalition nicht die Schuldenbremse für
alles mögliche im Bundeshaushalt
aufgehoben hätte sondern wie diese
Regierungskoalition sehr gezielt mit
Hilfsmaßnahmen nur die Schuldenbremse
ausgesetzt hätte der Grund warum wir im
kommenden Jahr im Vergleich zum Haushalt
2021 das Zehnfache an Zinsen zahlen
müssen liebe Kollegen ohne zu
investieren in Bildung in die Bundeswehr
und all die wichtigen Dinge die der Bund
tun muss nur für Zinsen ausgeben sind
ihre corona-schulden für alles mögliche
gewesen das war die Verantwortung der
cdu/csu in der Vergangenheit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und deswegen lösen wir das Versprechen
ein was wir gegeben haben trotz dieser
Herausforderung und der Erblasten dieser
Koalition erhöhen wir den
Investitionsanteil im Bundeshaushalt auf
die Rekordniveau in Höhe von 70
Milliarden Euro der erste echte Haushalt
dieser Koalition löst das Versprechen
des Koalitionsvertrages zur finanziellen
Solidität und zur Investition in die
Zukunft Deutschlands ein liebe
Kolleginnen versprochen gehalten das
muss an dieser Stelle bemerkt werden und
gleichzeitig sorgen wir für
milliardenschweren Entlastung im
kommenden Jahr nämlich steuerliche
Entlastung wie sie in Deutschland seit
Jahrzehnten nicht gegeben hat mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz liebe
Kollegen Kollegen schaffen wir die
umfangreichsten Entlastung und zwar in
Höhe von 50 Milliarden Euro in den
kommenden zwei Jahren wir gleichen die
kalte Progression vollständig aus der
Ausgleich der kalten Progression liebe
Kollegen ist das Zeichen an die hart
arbeitende Mitte in Deutschland leistung
lohnt sich auch steuerlich dafür steht
diese Regierungskoalition liebe Kollegen
Studenten Studentinnen und Studenten
werden bis zu 1.000 Euro mehr im Jahr
haben die größte Kindergelderhöhung in
der Geschichte unseres Landes auf 250
Euro pro Kind und jede Familie mit zwei
Kindern in Deutschland wird bis zu 2000
Euro mehr Netto in der Tasche haben
diese Koalition setzt ein Zeichen für
Leistung und Aufstieg das ist der Kern
an dieser Stelle seit Jahrzehnten wurden
die arbeitenden Menschen in diesem Land
nicht mehr so stark entlastet der
Ausgleich der kalten Progression ist das
erste wichtige Zeichen von
Leistungsgerechtigkeit dieser
Regierungskoalition liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und das zweite werden wir hoffentlich am
heutigen Abend setzen können und zwar
gemeinsam ich freue mich ausdrücklich
über den wahrscheinlich gefundenen
Kompromiss beim Bürgergeld der heute
Abend im Vermittlungsausschuss Thema
sein wird das aufstiegsversprechen der
zuzahlen Marktwirtschaft ist doch in
Wahrheit in Deutschland schon seit
langem beschädigt man könnte sagen es
ist teilweise kaputt gegangen für
Familien ist Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
seit Jahren eines der größten Risiken
verarmt mit dem neuen Bürgergeld gehen
wir also ein fundamentales
gerechtigkeitsproblem unseres
Sozialstaates an nach der alten
Rechtslage ich will das beispielhaft
sagen nach der alten Rechtslage würde
einem Auszubildenden von 800 Euro
Ausbildungsvergütung lediglich 240 Euro
übrig bleiben das ändert diese Koalition
über 600 Euro hat dieser junge Mensch
mehr in der Tasche auch da muss ich
Leistung lohnen gerade für junge
Menschen die in die Berufsausbildung
gehen und im Leben etwas leisten wollen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Kern dieses Bürgergeldes ist nämlich
das aufstiegsversprechen für diejenigen
einzulösen die es im Leben an schwersten
haben es geht um Arbeitsanreize die wir
verbessern werden insbesondere bei den
hinzuverdienstregeln und bei der
Weiterbildung und den
Qualifizierungsmöglichkeiten und da will
ich noch einmal eine Erinnerung rufen
wäre es hier komplett nach der Union
gegangen hätten wir heute kein
Bürgergeld und keine Aufstiegschancen
sondern wir hätten lediglich Hartz IV
mit höheren regensätzen das war für uns
als Koalition für mich als FDP-Politiker
zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Option diese
Koalition der Kern des Bürgergeldes ist
das aufstiegsversprechen und die
Arbeitsanreize endlich wieder in den
Sozialstaat zu bringen denn wir wollen
dass die Menschen von eigenen Hände
Arbeit leben können das ist das Signal
des Bürgergeldes liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und
seit der Rede des Bundeskanzlers
ist das Wort Zeitenwende auch immer hier
wieder richtigerweise erwähnt worden ja
geopolitisch geow wirtschaftlich muss
diese Koalition neu reagieren und
korrigieren was in der Vergangenheit an
Fehlern gemacht worden ist die
zeitenwände gilt deshalb insbesondere
auch für unseren Blick auf die Welt
meine Damen und Herren trotz aller
Anstrengungen die wir hier vor Ort
Unternehmen dürfen wir deshalb den Blick
fürs große und ganze nicht aus dem Blick
verlieren und Herr Merz sie haben
richtigerweise auch den systemwettbewerb
angesprochen beispielsweise mit China
sie haben die Handelspolitik der
Vereinigten Staaten angesprochen die uns
Probleme bereitet gerade unsere
mittelständischen Unternehmen ich teile
das ausdrücklich aber
als Antwort auf USA und China kommt als
erster konkreter Vorschlag des
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der cdu/csu die
Abschaffung der Verbandsklage in
Deutschland da werden die in Peking
zittern ich bin davon überzeugt die
kriegen alle Angst bei diesem Vorschlag
von liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja es ist richtig die internationale
Ordnung das Kräfteverhältnis und
wirtschaftlichen Sinne zwischen den
Ländern hat sich geändert und wir müssen
in der Gegenwart und in Zukunft
insbesondere auf die Demokratien in der
Welt setzen Deutschland muss seine
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit auf neue Füße
stellen und das gelingt eben nur mit den
richtigen internationalen Partnern an
unserer Seite Deutschlands
wirtschaftliche Stärke muss basieren auf
Diversifizierung freiem Handel
Kooperation Weltoffenheit und Demokratie
denn was wir jetzt brauchen ist doch
mehr Austausch und Handel mit den
Demokratien der Welt meine Damen und
Herren das bisherige Modell in
Deutschland günstige Energie von
Autokraten Absatzmärkte verstärkt in den
letzten Jahren in Diktaturen und hohe
Steuern in Deutschland dieses Modell hat
ein Fundament verloren für die Zukunft
muss es doch ganz klar unser
Geschäftsmodell sein dass wir auf die
Demokratien in der Welt setzen mit einer
neuen handelsagenter setzt diese
Koalition deshalb ein wichtiges Zeichen
der kommenden Woche des Deutschen
Bundestages meine Damen und Herren in
Bundestages werden wir das
Freihandelsabkommen ceta mit Kanada im
Deutschen Bundestag ratifizieren nach
dem Ihnen das jahrelang nicht gelungen
ist meine Damen und Herren das ist die
Zeitenwende das ist die Zeitenwende die
wir hier anstreben
aber aber
es soll ja es kann sich kann sich einer
von denen kann sich einer von den
heutigen Abgeordneten der
cdu/csu-fraktion daran erinnern dass sie
jemals einen freien Abkommen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag zugestimmt haben
nichts ist in den 16 Jahren passiert
nicht mal Zehnter nichts haben Sie
erreichbar beim Freunde gar nichts das
ist die Wahrheit
aber wir gehen weiter es soll doch nicht
bei ceta bleiben wir setzen uns für eine
Ratifizierung des merkursuabkommens ein
wir bringen die Freihandelsabkommen mit
Chile und mit Mexiko zum Abschluss und
meine Damen und Herren ich sprach vom
transatlantischen Feltes ich sprach
davon dass wir mit den Demokratien der
Welt zusammenarbeiten müssen diese
Koalition strebt einen neuen Anlauf zu
einem transatlantischen Abkommen mit den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika an auch
das ist ein wichtiges Zeichen dieser
Regierungsmehrheit im Deutschen
Bundestag meine Damen und Herren
und deswegen will ich das zum Schluss
sagen all die Dinge die wir jetzt
konkret in dieser Woche mit dem
Bundeshaushalt 2023 machen und das was
wir politisch vereinbart haben und
bereits auf den Weg gebracht haben bei
der planungsbeschleunigung
beispielsweise das was wir in
Wilhelmshaven geschafft haben ist
geradezu eine Blaupause für das was wir
in Deutschland machen müssen
insbesondere bei der Energiepolitik ich
sprach es an aber auch ganz konkret bei
den Zukunftsthemen beispielsweise die
Sicherung der sozialen Sicherungssysteme
in Deutschland insbesondere bei der
Rente Deutschland steht vor einer
demografischen Krise meine Damen und
Herren diese Regierungsmehrheit diese
Bundesregierung hat sich auf die Fahnen
geschrieben sich dieser Aufgabe endlich
zu stellen mit der aktienrente führen
wir kapitalbasierungen in die erste
Säule der deutschen Rentenversicherung
ein das ist eine Zeiten wenn der auch
für die sozialen Sicherungssysteme in
unserem Land liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und zum Schluss
Deutschland steht vor einer
demografischen Krise insbesondere auch
weil die Union über Jahre wahrscheinlich
Jahrzehnte negiert hat dass Deutschland
ein Einwanderungsland ist ja auch
deshalb bei Einwanderungspolitik in den
letzten Jahren nicht stattgefunden hat
weil sie es regelmäßig insbesondere ihre
Innenminister regelmäßig verhindert
haben der Wohlstand in Deutschland
beruht auf bessere Energiepolitik in der
Zukunft aber er beruht eben auch darauf
dass wir ausreichend Menschen am
Arbeitsmarkt haben deswegen wird diese
Koalition ihr Versprechen einlösen ein
Einwanderungsgesetz für den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt damit unter Mittelstand
florieren kann damit die Industrie
florieren kann und damit wir den
Wohlstand in Zukunft in Deutschland
sichern das Versprechen lösen wir ein
ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Christian höher war das der Vorsitzende
der FDP-Fraktion mit einer ganzen Reihe
von na Angriffen in Richtung
Unionsfraktion aber betont vor allem die
Punkte die die FDP in dieser Koalition
machen möchte
ich gehe davon aus dass beide Frau
Merkel und auch Herr Merz ist von sich
weisen würden miteinander verheiratet zu
sein
insofern korrigiere ich das für Sie
gerne mit
und das hätte ich ihnen sowieso noch
gesagt meine Damen und Herren das wird
ein Satz sein der ist auch in die eine
oder andere Sendung schaffen wird von
Christian dürr hat nämlich gesagt Sie
haben es in der Rede nicht untergebracht
Herr Merkel und das hatte Bärbel Basti
Bundestagspräsidentin hier jetzt auch
noch mal stellvertretend für ihn
korrigiert während auf dem Weg zum
polten ein sogar schon angekommen ist
Alexander Dobrind der Vorsitzende der
CSU Landesgruppe
von anderen Themen in ihrer Rede
erheblich wundern es scheint ja manches
durcheinander gegangen zu sein wenn sie
davon reden dass jetzt endlich
Freihandelsabkommen abgeschlossen werden
ceta kommt jetzt ein Freihandelsabkommen
mit der USA wird jetzt gemacht unter
blicken Sie mal in diese rein kein
einziger Hand bei der SPD hat sich
bewegt und da kommen sie auf den
Gedanken es lag an der Union dass wir
diese heiraten
lieber Herr dürfte
man muss sich mit ihrer Rede weiter
beschäftigen weil sie ja ganz
offensichtlich vieles durcheinander
bringen sie verwechseln wir auch
Fortschritt in der fortschrittskoalition
mit ganz offensichtlicher Verschleierung
sie reden von der Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr das Geld
dafür beschaffen Sie sich in diesem Jahr
sie reden von
rekordinvestitionen ein wesentlicher
Teil 10 Milliarden das ist der
fdp-beitrag zur Rentenversicherung ihre
aktienrente sie reden von soliden
Finanzen schaffen aber einen
Schattenhaushalt nach den anderen sie
geben dem Wort Schattenkabinett eine
ganz neue Bedeutung Erde
so sie verwechseln Fortschritt mit
Verschleierung und übrigens die
verwechseln auch Investitionsquote mit
illusionsquote das ist die Realität in
ihrem Haushalt
und sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sie
bedienen sich hier wenn wir schon bei
Illusionen sind sie bedienen sich hier
alles im Wunderland was groß ist ist
klein was klein ist ist groß zu ihren
ihre Worte mir fehlt ehrlich bei dieser
Bundesregierung nur eins ein Jim Knopf
und der Scheinriese je näher man ihrer
Bundesregierung kommt umso kleiner
werden ihre politischen Leistungen das
ist die Realität
der Bundeskanzler sie haben hier am
Rednerpult vorhin betont sie wollen und
Sie werden zwei Prozent in die
Verteidigung investieren das Problem ist
doch nur sie machen es nicht der
Bundeskanzler sie haben gesagt es müssen
erst Maschine angeschafft werden damit
überhaupt irgendwas produziert werden
kann ja geht es eigentlich noch kleiner
in der Argumentation ihr für ihre
Verteidigungsministerin hat bei den
Verhandlungen zu den 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen zugesagt dass sie noch in
diesem Jahr 10 Milliarden an Munition
beschaffen wird keine einzige Patrone
ist bisher bestellt worden das Problem
der Bundeskanzler sind nicht die
fehlenden Maschinen in Deutschland
sondern die fehlende Führung in ihren
Verteidigungsministerium das ist es geht
bei der Einbringung dieses Haushalts der
Bundeskanzler am 7 september haben sie
uns noch sehr bescheiden mitgeteilt dass
sie die energieversorgungsprobleme
bereits gelöst hätten bevor wir sie
überhaupt erkannt hätten wie ihre Lösung
ausschaut das sagt uns vorgestern ihr
Behördenchef der Netzagentur Klaus
Müller auf Twitter ich zitiere wörtlich
keine Panik so kann es tatsächlich zu
Stromabschaltungen im Winter kommen doch
diese dürfen meist vorab angekündigt
werden und maximal vier Stunden dauern
sehr geehrter Bundeskanzler vier Stunden
blick-erklärung ihre Energiepolitik
Frau Kollege dröge sie haben hier vorhin
als Vorsitzender einer
Regierungsfraktion wie sie sich ja
zurecht benannt haben davon gesprochen
dass ab dem Jahr 2023 keine Gasheizungen
mehr eingebaut werden dürfen an welcher
Stelle dieses Koalitionsvertrag steht
das eigentlich ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
ich habe es nicht gefunden vielleicht
sollten Sie das mal aufklären entweder
war diese Aussage frei erfunden oder Sie
haben gerade eine ganze Branche in die
Insolvenz geschickt das ist ein
grundlegender Fehler
den Sie hier begangen haben korrigieren
Sie das bitte an dieser Stelle und meine
Damen und Herren dass die Lage so
dramatisch am Energiemarkt ist das haben
wir in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
intensivst ja auch diskutiert übrigens
auch mit unseren Nachbarländern weil wir
auf Strom Lieferungen dieser
Nachbarländer angewiesen sind sie haben
allerdings sie Habeck eine ganz
offensichtlich hohe Bereitschaft unsere
europäischen Partner vor den Kopf zu
stoßen das schafft kein zusätzliches
Vertrauen sie haben den letzten Monaten
mit der Übernahme von Juniper auch
unternehmerische Verantwortung für die
Energiepolitik in Deutschland übernommen
und sie haben unternehmerische
Verantwortung für die Energiepolitik
gehen anderen europäischen Ländern damit
übernommen die Schweden beißt sich Weise
setzen neben der Wasserkraft und anderen
erneuerbaren Energien weiter auf die
Kern Energie uniper betreibt dort in
Schweden auch die Kernkraftwerke der Bau
eines weiteren Kernkraftwerks das in
Schweden geplant ist wurde jetzt von
Juniper aus Deutschland heraus
öffentlich abgesagt und Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister die
schwedische Energieministerin Epper
Busch wurde zu keinem Zeitpunkt von
ihnen darüber informiert wenn das der
Umgang mit unseren europäischen Partnern
ist dann schaffen sie kein
zusammenwachsen in Europa sondern sie
isolieren Deutschland energiepolitische
in Europa
sehr geehrter Herr
Bundesfinanzminister sie haben hier in
ihrer Haushaltsrede am 8 September
gesagt ich zitiere Inflation bekämpft
man nicht mit immer neuen Staatsschulden
sondern nur dadurch dass man zurück zur
Seriosität und Solidität findet diese
Aussage ist richtig aber zwischen ihrer
Rede und dem heutigen Tag liegen
250 Milliarden Euro weitere neue
Schulden und die Inflationsrate ist von
7,9 auf 10,4 Prozent gestiegen die Ampel
hat jetzt 550 Milliarden neue Schulden
aufgenommen das ist der Schuldenstand
den alle Bundesländer zusammen seit der
Gründung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
geschaffen haben das ist die Realität
die hier im Haushaltsansatz
so und dabei sagen sie nach wie vor
nicht genau für was sie dieses Geld und
zu welchem Zeitpunkt die dieses Geld
nehmen Anspruch nehmen wollen Sie
bauen einen großen schuldensack auf in
ihrem Keller des Finanzministeriums und
Glauben offensichtlich daran dass er in
den nächsten Monaten da unbehelligt
stehen wird schauen Sie sich doch bitte
mal ihre
Koalitionspartner an das ist wie mit dem
Hund und dem wurstvorrat das kann an
dieser Stelle bei definitiv nicht gut
gehen und deswegen rate ich Ihnen
dringend kehren Sie zur Solidität zurück
nehmen Sie doch Ihre eigene Worte ernst
und vertrauen sie doch nicht ihren
Koalitionspartner dass sie ihr Geld Satz
im Keller zufrieden lassen
[Applaus]
sie haben den ihrer Rede gestern der
Bundesfinanzminister deutlich gemacht
dass sich diese Bundesregierung
entschieden hätte keine Steuererhöhungen
vorzunehmen dass irritiert jetzt etwas
weil wir zurzeit Hochkonjunktur bei den
Notaren erleben in Vorbereitung ihres
Jahressteuergesetzes bei dem zu erwarten
ist dass erbschafts- und Schenkung
Steuern für Immobilien massiv erhöht
werden sie haben in ihrer Rede dazu
definitiv nichts gesagt ich kann Ihnen
sagen die Angst ist berechtigt und sie
ist groß ein erbrechtsexperte hat jetzt
auch nachgerechnet dass bei dem vererben
oder verschenken eines Hauses die
Erbschaftssteuer deutlich ansteigt bei
einem Wertanstieg von 61% führt das dazu
dass das Häuschen das bisher für 10.000
Euro verschenkt vererbt worden ist jetzt
60.000 Euro neue
schenkungssteuerbedarf sehr geehrte Herr
Bundes Finanzminister wir brauchen keine
Steuererhöhungen auf Immobilien durch
die Hintertür wir brauchen hohe
Freibeträge damit keine Erbschaftssteuer
beim Übergang von Immobilien stattfindet
und deswegen sage ich Ihnen an dieser
Stelle da zitiere ich ihren
Parteikollegen Kubicki der Spaß hört
jetzt endlich auf die SPD fordert hier
die Vermögensabgabe die Grünen fordern
die Steuererhöhungen und das
Finanzministerium das ist für die
Erbschaftssteuer zuständig das ist eine
Grund falsche Aufstellung dieser
Regierung wir brauchen endlich die
Freibeträge damit es zu keinen
steuerhöhungen durch die hinter dir
kommt die Leute haben berechtigt Angst
davor dass Immobilien nicht vererbt
werden können weil sie ihnen in die
Tasche greifen wollen das ist die dieser
Politik dieser Bundesregierung
Alexander Dobrindt ist Vorsitzender der
CSU-Landesgruppe und erster
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
Unionsfraktion hat hier mancherlei
Angriffe gerichtet in Richtung Christian
Dörr Richtung Lindner Christian Lindner
und wir können feststellen Union und der
FDP werden in absehbarer Zeit zumindest
keine besonders dicken Freunde werden
wenn man diesen Worten hier folgt
ansonsten ein Feuerwerk der Vergleiche
heute in der Generaldebatte auch viel
Kinder und Jugendliteratur die hier
zitiert wird wir sind gespannt wie es
weitergeht alles im Wunderland haben wir
schon gehört Jim Knopf jetzt aber
erstmal Rolf Mütze nicht der Vorsitzende
der SPD-Fraktion
wir leben in extremen und anstrengenden
Zeiten und der von Präsident Putin
wissentlich und willentlich entfachte
Krieg ist die schlimmste Form extremer
Politik aber auch das abgleitendes
stabiler Demokratien oder die Leugnung
des Klimawandels sind folgen und zeugen
von Radikalität und Ignoranz und
deswegen meine Damen und Herren in
diesem Umfeld wächst die Versuchung zu
extremen politischen Debatten leider
auch bei uns und ich denke wir
DemokratInnen und Demokraten müssen uns
diesen Extremismus entgegenstellen meine
Damen und Herren
weil nämlich die Wirklichkeit komplex
ist müssen wir den vereinfachen mit
unserer Fähigkeit zur Vernunft und zum
Kompromiss begegnen
regorismus ist Gift für den notwendigen
Zusammenhalt und für eine kluge Politik
Besonderheit Pluralismus und ein
Höchstmaß an Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit
sind die Voraussetzungen für den inneren
und äußeren Frieden meine Damen und
Herren Deutschland
hat hierbei eine wichtige Rolle und
natürlich auch eine Koalition so
unterschiedlicher Parteien deshalb
müssen wir und davon bin ich überzeugt
die einzigartige Chance nutzen in einem
Bündnis
gleichberechtigter Parteien wollen wir
unsere gemeinsam Anliegen für Freiheit
Gerechtigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit bündeln
und einlösen mit Augenmaß und dem Sinn
für neue Realitäten das ist der Auftrag
für eine Koalition des Fortschritts und
wir sind stolz mit Olaf Scholz an der
Spitze daran mitwirken zu dürfen meine
Damen und Herren und die Gesetzgebung
die Gesetzgebung der letzten Monate und
eben um was es heute hier geht der neue
Haushalt ergänzen sich das ist eine
kluge Politik und der
Bundesfinanzminister hat zum Abschluss
der Haushaltsberatung zur
Bereinigungssitzung die Haushälterinnen
und Haushälter wenn ich mich recht
entsinne als interessantes Völkchen
bezeichnete ich nehme an daraus klingt
Sympathie und Unterstützung und Respekt
ich will einfach sagen es sind
selbstbewusst und kompetente Abgeordnete
ausgestattet mit dem Vertrauen des
Souveräns die noch mal 31 Milliarden
Euro bewegt haben meine Damen und Herren
eben weil wir uns auf nachhaltige
öffentliche Güter wie Arbeit wohnen
Bildung und Mobilität konzentrieren hat
es sich gelohnt diesen Haushalt noch mal
zu verbessern und ich bin der festen
Überzeugung dass dieser Haushalt uns
auch gut durch das neue Jahr tragen wird
aber gleichzeitig schafft diese Haushalt
eben auch die Voraussetzung für den
Umbau der Wirtschaft für eine
klimaneutrale Produktion für neue und
gut bezahlte Arbeitsplätze und
gleichzeitig eben auch für Ideen bei
diesen Herausforderungen meine Damen und
Herren müssen wir vorankommen und im
Vergleich
zu den vielen Jahrhunderten vor uns wo
der Strukturwandel immer über
Gesellschaften hereingebrochen ist haben
wir diesmal die einzigartige Chance
diesen Strukturwandel vorab ein Weg zu
geben einen Pfad und das ist auch die
Konsequenz und der Auftrag an diese
Koalition wir können ein modernes
Deutschland schaffen dass sich in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten auch in einem neuen
internationalen Umfeld behaupten kann
und muss aber meine Damen und Herren
natürlich ist diese Agenda überlagert
von einem brutalen Krieg insbesondere
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung aber bei
unserem Innern
hervorgerufen eine Energiekrise und eben
auch ein wachsenden Kaufkraftverlust
aber es ist unbestritten dass wir eben
die Ukraine die so brutal und mit Lügen
aufgebaut angegriffen worden ist unter
unterstützen müssen ja mit Waffen und
gleichzeitig aber auch mit humanitärer
Hilfe und einer finanziellen
Unterstützung die schon vor dem Krieg
von Seiten Deutschland sehr groß
geworden ist und das ist der eine Teil
der Medaille und der andere Teil ist der
Entgrenzung des Krieges vorzubeugen
durch eine kluge Politik und
das muss man sich jeden Tag neu
erarbeiten und das tut die
Bundesregierung das tut der
Bundeskanzler und deswegen bedauere ich
das vor dem Hintergrund aktuelle
Ereignisse des Raketen Einschlags in
Polen manche übereilt manche auch finde
ich zu gefährlich und risikofvoll
reagiert haben nämlich dieser
Entgrenzung des Krieges müssen wir
vorbeugen und dazu gehört auch der einen
Seite die Ukraine zu unterstützen aber
auch der anderen Seite auch eine kluge
Diplomatie so wie es der Bundeskanzler
gemacht hat zu unternehmen Reise
Diplomatie aber insbesondere eben die
Länder mitzunehmen die nicht unmittelbar
am Anfang dieses Krieges auch auf der
Seite derjenigen gestanden haben der 141
Staaten sondern die sich der Stimme
enthalten haben aber trotzdem gegen den
Krieg sind und die muss man mitnehmen
und deswegen war es richtig diese Länder
zum G7 Gipfel einzuladen in diese Länder
zu reisen man muss mit wir sprechen die
mit einem nicht dergleichen Meinung von
Anfang an sind deswegen ist Diplomatie
kein Relikt vergangener Tage sondern
aktueller denn je deswegen auf der einen
Seite eine kluge Außenpolitik auf der
anderen Seite eine kluge Sozialpolitik
die sich den inneren Herausforderungen
stellt und ich bin froh dass unsere
Fraktion meine Fraktion in Dresden drei
notwendige Bedingungen formuliert hat
die auch sozusagen den Fans
vorgezeichnet haben für diesen Weg auf
der einen Seite
unmittelbare soziale direkte Hilfen auf
der anderen Seite eine Grundsicherung an
bezahlbarer Energiesicherheit und
Zuversicht für die Verbraucher aber da
hängt ja doch mehr mit dazu wir wollen
den
industriellen Kern auch mit dieser
Grundsicherung in Deutschland erhalten
wir wollen uns dem was die USA zurzeit
versucht auch zu wachsen mit einer
günstigen Energie aber gleichzeitig sage
ich dann auch Voraussetzung ist mit
dieser Frage der Grundsicherung an
Energie muss auch Standortsicherung in
Deutschland garantiert werden und
letztlich Beschäftigungssicherung weil
wir die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer in dieser Arbeit halten
wollen und deswegen war es gut dass die
Bundesregierung zusammen mit den sie
tragenden Parteien auch die konzertierte
Aktion auf den Weg gebracht hat
Anknüpfen an die guten Erfahrungen
vergangener Jahrzehnte auch eben hier
Unterstützung gegeben hat die
Tarifvertragsparteien an ihre Pflichten
erinnert hat gute Arbeit mit gut
bezahltem Einkommen zu unterlegen aber
auf der anderen Seite auch
Abgabenfreiheit Steuerfreiheit mit
anzubieten und alle Verantwortlichen
Tarifvertragsparteien haben in den
vergangenen Wochen zu diesem Mittel
gegriffen und das schafft Solidarität
auf der einen Seite aber auch zuver für
die Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
meine Damen und Herren deswegen war die
konzertierte Aktion eine wichtige
Bedingung und gerade auch für uns
Sozialdemokratien und Sozialdemokraten
die so eng mit den Gewerkschaften
zusammenarbeiten war das ein gutes
Signal meine Damen und Herren und die
zweite Bedingung die wir damals auf
unserer Klausur im September in Dresden
formuliert haben ist die Menschen dürfen
nicht von Almosen abhängen sie brauchen
soziale Rechte in dieser Gesellschaft
deswegen der Mindestlohn aber auch die
Ausweitung der wohngeld-empfänger aber
was noch wichtiger ist in den letzten
Wochen was wir gemeinsam geschaffen
haben ist die Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
auf 250 € jedes Kind ist gleich viel
wert meine Damen und Herren und genau
das ist die Basis für eine
Kindergrundsicherung wovon ich jetzt
auch die Bundesregierung bitte diese
Kindergrundsicherung anzupacken und sie
noch in dieser Legislatur wurde zu
verwirklichen wir haben die Basis meine
Damen und Herren durch die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes gelegt zum anderen das
Bürgergeld ein gutes Ergebnis ich lass
mal einfach zur Seite wer sich wo
irgendwo durchgesetzt hat in paar Wochen
interessiert dass die Menschen überhaupt
nicht mehr wichtig ist
Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung der
Wert der Arbeit auch über diese
Grundsicherung über dieses Bürgergeld zu
erhalten aber was es noch ist es ist ein
Basisschutz für die Demokratie in einem
sozialen bundesstand das was uns die
Väter und die Mütter des Grundgesetzes
auferlegt haben ist dass das Bürgergeld
eine Rückversicherung dafür ist und die
dritte Bedingung systemische Eingriffe
dort oder sogenannte Markt der da alles
richtet eben auch aufgehalten und
korrigiert wird und auch das Verlangen
wir in den nächsten Tagen wenn die
Vorlagen da sind dass wir uns das genau
anschauen ob das eben auch erreichen
meine Damen und Herren ich habe von
extrem und anstrengenden Zeiten
gesprochen sie sind nicht mehr so wie in
den vergangenen Jahrzehnten wir müssen
uns das endlich vor Augen führen leider
repräsentieren Diktaturen autoritäre
Regierung mittlerweile 70 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung liberale Demokratien
sind auf dem niedrigsten Stand angelangt
deswegen war es für mich auch bitter zu
erfahren dass es in der Europäischen
Union wie zum Beispiel im gründungsland
Italien mittlerweile Parteien an der
Spitze sind die diesem Extremismus eben
auch das Feld bereiten aber ich sage
auch gleichzeitig ohne Hoffnung können
wir die Demokratie nicht verteidigen
deswegen sind die Lichtblicke der
Wahlausgang in Brasilien meine Damen und
Herren die mitturms in den USA die
deutlich Ernüchterung über den brexit in
Großbritannien ja es ist anstrengend wir
müssen dem mit Ernsthaftigkeit und
Sachlichkeit entgegenstehen
aber ich bin überzeugt dass Demokratien
die Probleme am besten lösen können das
können wir gemeinsam beweisen meine
Damen und Herren vielen Dank
wolfenmütze nicht weil das der
Vorsitzende der SPD-Fraktion mit einem
Schwerpunkt Außenpolitik und Diplomatie
das ist ja seit längerer Zeit schon sein
Spezialgebiet ist auch im
außenpolitischer Sprecher gewesen der
SPD-Fraktion und wir sind aber
nichtsdestotrotz immer noch in der
Generaldebatte zum
des Bundeshaushalt 2023 und da ist der
nächste Redner Kino aus der afd-fraktion
12 Monate Bundesregierung wie sieht
eigentlich aktuell unser Land aus die
Inflation treibt Deutschland seine
Bürger und die heimische Wirtschaft
immer mehr um die Spirale dreht sich
immer weiter und schneller Entwertung
des Geldes sinkt eine Kaufkraft
rückläufiger absatzumsatz Menschen
halten das Geld zusammen ist ganz
verständlich geringere
investitionsleistungen von Unternehmen
sind die Folge und im Gegenzug die
steigende staatliche Transfer und
Unterstützungsleistungen gleichzeitig
fehlen mehr und mehr Arbeitskräfte die
überhaupt noch zur Wertschöpfung
beitragen können und sie gehen wieder
auf das übliche Patentrezept zurück
weitere Migrationen mittlerweile
Höchststände die das Jahr 2015 schon
übersteigen welche Erfolge für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland haben
sie damit eigentlich erreicht in welchem
Verhältnis stehen diese Investitionen
und der volkswirtschaftlich
erwirtschaftete gewinnen überhaupt noch
und nein ich spreche nicht von
Kriegsflüchtlingen die hier um ich
spreche von denen die nicht in dieses
System integrierbar sind von
Transferleistungen leben müssen aber
gewalttätig in unserem Land auftreten
die können und wollen wir uns nicht
länger leisten meine Damen und Herren
und deshalb nutzen Sie nutzen sie
endlich die rechtlichen Möglichkeiten
voll aus die Dublin-Abkommen genauso
über die redeten mittlerweile überhaupt
niemand mehr wie die Rückführung in die
Heimatländer das gehört auch zur
Wahrheit dazu diese Regierungspolitik
bringt unser Land immer weiter in
Ungleichgewicht und die Verantwortlichen
Bundesminister steuerbern von Woche zu
Woche ohne eine langfristige Vision zu
haben die investieren nicht in unser
Land in unsere kritische Infrastruktur
sondern in die Werte geleitet der
Außenpolitik das ist ihr Schlagwort mit
den Sanktionen geplanten Schaden Sie uns
unseren Bürgern und unserer Wirtschaft
in Deutschland und das wird jeden Tag
offensichtlicher weder Russland noch
China sind auf uns überhaupt angewiesen
neue Märkte haben diese Länder seit
Jahren bereits erschlossen nur wir
leisten uns kein Teil mehr davon sein zu
wollen und das ist purer Übermut wir
haben
wir haben weder Gas noch Öl vorkommen
und investieren seit Jahrzehnten in
nicht grundlastfähige Energieträger wir
brauchen aber eine stabile und
zuverlässige Energieversorgung deshalb
muss auch nordstream als ein Teil davon
repariert im Betrieb genommen und auch
gesichert werden wir haben es heute
schon gehört der Bundeskanzler hat
übrigens da auch Aufklärung versprochen
es wird totgeschwiegen es kommt dazu
nichts sagen Sie es doch wer von unseren
Freunden dafür Verantwortung trägt sie
machen es nicht es ist einfach eine
Schande deswegen wir brauchen in unserem
Land Stabilität und Zuversicht weshalb
sollte eigentlich ein Unternehmen sich
überhaupt noch in Deutschland ansiedeln
überhaupt noch diesen Standort hier
wählen das verraten sie nicht nehmen wir
das Beispiel der BASF die Bürger an den
alten Bundesländern werden wohl genau
das gleiche Schicksal alleine wie die
Bürger der neuen Bundesländer nach 1990
führen werden abwandern Regionen werden
die industrialisiert Arbeitsplätze
verschwinden und junge Menschen ziehen
weg genau das scheint wahrscheinlich das
Ziel anderen Wirtschaftsminister Habig
zu sein ihre Politik der
Symptombekämpfung beseitigt die Ursachen
der Misere im genaue nicht wer sich als
Bundeswirtschaftsminister leichtsinnig
in einen Wirtschaftskrieg begibt hat
einfach nur versagt dieser
Wirtschaftsminister ist der schlechteste
der Bundesrepublik er ist wirklich eine
Schande für dieses Land
und unsere Nachbarn zeigen wie es anders
funktioniert bezahlbare
Energieversorgung oder auch eine
geringere Steuerlast überall in Europa
vor allem richten die Verantwortlichen
Regierung ihr Handeln eben auf die
Bereitstellung von Strukturen aus das
ist der Auftrag der Politik und nicht
Ideologie getriebene und starrsinnige
Projekte auf Kosten des Bundeshaushalts
und damit auch der Steuerzahler es
braucht endlich wieder den Willen für
unser eigenes Land für unsere Bürger
eine vernünftige und verlässliche
Politik zu machen und das vermissen wir
bei Ihnen Herr Bundeskanzler und ihre
andere Regierung von Anbeginn sie sorgen
dafür dass die Idee Industrialisierung
Deutschlands immer weiter vorangetrieben
wird dass sich der Wohlstand und die
Vermögen dezimieren weite Teile der
Bürger leben mittlerweile nur noch von
der Substanz ihre Lösung die Steuern
Mikrobereich nach und feiern die
sogenannten entlastungspakete
200 Euro für Studenten 300 Euro für
Rentner bei einer Inflation die
mittlerweile weit über zehn Prozent ist
das ist am Ende was ankommt im Vergleich
zur Inflation sind es nur Allmosen die
Sie auszahlen aber die staatlichen
Zuschüsse dürfen nicht immer weiter
ansteigen das gefährdet unseren
Sozialstaat in Gänze erklären Sie den
Bürgern bitte auch dass die Schulden
gemeinsame Schulden sind gleiches gilt
für die sogenannten Sondervermögen es
war doch absehbar dass sie genau an
diesen Instrument Gefallen gefunden
haben dass diese dieses Instrument
ausnutzen damit sie den Bundeshaushalt
weiter umgehen können sondern Vermögen
sind Schulden die wir alle bezahlen
müssen alle Bürger in diesem Land
und ich bleibe dabei was ich auch schon
vor der letzten Bundestagswahl gesagt
habe das ist hier eben ein Kassensturz
geben muss den der Finanzminister
durchführen muss genau das ist Ziel wir
haben es ja erlebt wie der
personalaufwuchs gerade dieser
Bundesregierung jetzt vonstatten
gegangen ist 1700 neue Stellen aufwuchs
in den Ministerien in diesen Zeiten die
Menschen predigen sie sie wollen für die
Ukraine frieren und selbst vergrößern
sie noch einmal den Wasserkopf und die
mangelverwalter die die Bürger alle
durchfüttern müssen in diesen
wirtschaftlichen Zeiten ist das einfach
nur unerhört und auch unverschämt
und dann komme ich noch zur Studie des
Ifo-Institut denn die zeichnet genau
dieses düstere Bild bei den
Grundfertigkeiten wie Lesen Schreiben
und Rechnen fallen wir mittlerweile im
internationalen Vergleich auf Platz 30
diese und die Vorgängerregierung
beklagen seit Jahren den Mangel an
Fachkräften wir haben heute wieder
gehört und wie man es lösen möchte
gleichzeitig begrenzen Sie alles auf das
Mittelmaß und da muss man sich nur noch
die bundesbildungsbericht mal anschauen
was der besagt
52.000 junge Menschen sind im Jahr 2021
ohne Schulabschluss von der Schule
gegangen in der altersvorhorte der 20
bis 34-Jährigen sind mittlerweile 2,2
Millionen junge Menschen ohne Berufs-
und Studienabschlüsse ein Großteil sitzt
ja hier
[Applaus]
1,2 Millionen von diesen sind
beschäftigt erwerbstätig aber nur am
Niedriglohnsektor genau eine Million
geht genau in Hartz IV bzw zukünftigen
ihr Bürgergeld und werden dort auch
bleiben das ist das Ergebnis was sie als
Bundesregierung und der letzten im
übrigen
sie haben die Verantwortung für unsere
Jugend aufgegeben und wollen es nur
durch Zuwanderung lösen das ist der
fatale Fehler und dafür sind sie
verantwortlich
und im Ergebnis haben wir neue
Generationen die genauso weit denken und
handeln können wie es die Ideologien der
Bundesregierung zulassen mittlerweile
geschaffen das wollen sie wahrscheinlich
sie werden die Bundesregierung sind die
Ware Fortschritts und Entwicklungsbremse
für dieses Land für Deutschland und
damit für den gesamten Kontinent Europa
und welche eigenen nicht brennt
bestimmten ideale sie haben sieht man ja
ein Bundeskanzler der bei der
auslandsbesuche nicht in seiner
Muttersprache spricht oder eine
Außenministerin die glaubt mit Freunden
zu sprechen wenn sie auf polnisch
twittert daran sieht man welche ideale
sie haben das sind Ausverkauf von
unseren Interessen denn unsere
Interessen stehen für alle Staaten im
Vordergrund das sollte eigentlich die
Prämisse sein nur nicht für diese
Bundesregierung ihre Politik des Freund
feinschema ist aus einer anderen Zeit
sie brechen Brücken ab und sie schlagen
Türen zu die Generation vor ihnen für
uns aufgebaut und offen gehalten haben
das war das Erfolgsrezept im Übrigen
eine erfolgreichen Wirtschaftsnation die
machen es bin von Monaten und Jahren
dazu Nichte wir verfügen heute
über Kern und Kohlekraftwerke aber aus
Klima ideologischen Gründen begeben wir
uns lieber wieder in eine einseitige
Abhängigkeit eine Unglaubwürdigkeit
folgt der nächsten und sie sind dabei
vollkommen ungehemmt einerseits dürfen
wir kein russisches Gas mehr beziehen
auch aus Gründen der einseitigen
Abhängigkeit andererseits begeben wir
uns in die Hände der sogenannten Freunde
die seit Jahrzehnten rund um den Globus
ihre wirtschaftskriege führen wo ist
hier ihre Moralen wo sind hier ihre
Werte
wir können alle zum Glück hier ein
Spielzeug des transatlantischen Projekts
eine halbe Minute habe ich steigen sie
von ihren Elfenbeinturm herab und machen
Sie Politik für Deutschland für unser
Land zuerst
gegen sie vielen Dank
Tilo krupala ist Fraktionsvorsitzender
der AFD wird jetzt noch mal ermahnt
bezogen
es steht ihnen nicht zu die amtierende
Präsidentin hier in dieser Weise zu
kritisieren wenn es dort etwas zu regeln
gibt
bringt das ihre parlamentarische
Geschäftsführung ganz sicher morgen im
Ältestenrat vor und jetzt für alle weil
wir sind in einer haushaltswoche da
gelten andere Regeln wenn es um die
Anrechnung der Redezeit geht da ist es
nämlich so dass ich sie zwar darauf
aufmerksam machen kann dass sie
weiterreden können das habe ich gerade
getan auch im Interesse ihrer anderen
Fraktionskollegen weil ich die Redezeit
die sie überziehen jetzt den nächsten
Rednern abziehe und das kann ja im Alter
einfach das Gefechts mal passieren so
wie ich eben auch die Redezeit die
verbliebene Rest Redezeit der
SPD-Fraktion korrigiert haben nachdem
der Kollege Mütze nicht zwei Minuten
überzogen hat
also ich diskutiere ich diskutiere dass
ihr überhaupt nicht mit ihrer Fraktion
und der nächste
so ich herbrandtner ich diskutiere das
nicht mit ihnen sondern
wir Verfahren so ich werde diese
Dienstleistung in der weiteren
sitzungsführung für ihre Fraktion nicht
mehr vollziehen sondern wenn der Redner
die gesamtretezeit der Fraktion ausnutzt
dann gibt es eben keinen weiteren Redner
der AFD so einfach ist das
[Applaus]
so der nächste jetzt haben wir noch was
gelernt über parlamentarische
Gepflogenheiten auch was die Redezeiten
in einer haushaltswoche angeht so ganz
fremd ist das Prozedere eigentlich nicht
Andreas ist bereits am Pult ist der
nächste Redner einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Damen und Herren
Herr kropalla die Propaganda moskauz
immer wieder hier im Bundestag anhören
zu müssen ist immer wieder
unerträglicher bei ihnen laufen ja
mittlerweile schon die eigenen
Abgeordneten weg damit zeigt glaube ich
dass sehr deutlich dass auch in ihrer
Fraktion ist einige gibt den auffällt
dass sie nichts anderes tun als hier die
Propaganda moskas zu verbreiten das was
wir tun ist in der gleichen Zeit und um
die Menschen zu kümmern und zweitens das
Land zu modernisieren wir kümmern uns
auch um die Kulturbranche in diesem Land
die hat einen sehr sehr schwierigen
stand und das ist nicht nur dieser Krise
geschuldet das hat in corona-zeiten
begonnen wenn in der corona-zeit viele
Menschen nicht mehr ins Theater gegangen
sind wenn viele Menschen nicht mehr in
Lesungen gegangen sind dann ist das
etwas was ich bis heute noch nicht
wieder normalisiert hat und dann fällt
es den theaternen Kultureinrichtungen
schwer jetzt steigende Energiepreise auf
Tickets umzulegen und genau deswegen ist
es so wichtig auch für die Kulturbranche
das Robert Habeck die das heißt Bremse
auf den Weg bringt das Robert Habeck die
strompreisbremse auf den Weg bringt aber
wir begnügen uns nicht damit wir nehmen
ganz gezielt auch die Kulturbranche noch
mal in den Blick und haben dafür eine
Milliarde Euro ganz gezielt extra im
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds zur
Verfügung gestellt eines muss klar sein
wir sehen die Kulturbranche und wir
haben genau diese Branche jetzt im Blick
wir haben nicht nur die Institutionen im
Blick wir haben auch die Menschen in
dieser Krise im Blick und haben schon 22
im Jahr 22 die Künstlersozialkasse so
stabilisiert dass jetzt die Beiträge
nicht durch die Decke gehen und was wäre
auch machen und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir uns anschauen was heute
Abend im Vermittlungsausschuss passiert
wir stärken freischaffende wir stärken
selbstständige durch das Bürgergeld und
auch deswegen ist es so wichtig dass das
heute abend im Vermittlungsausschuss
verabschiedet wird schauen wir auf die
Karenzzeit was machen wir mit mit der
Karenzzeit die Karenzzeit gibt
Sicherheit gerade freischaffenden gerade
Kulturschaffenden das wenn sie in eine
Notsituation kommen dass sie dann nicht
als allererstes die Wohnung aufgeben
müssen sondern dass sie sich darauf
konzentrieren können das ist weitergeht
und genau diese Leute haben häufig einen
Plan wie es weitergeben kann dass Sie
nicht Ihr kleinstes Erspartes direkt
abgeben müssen wenn sie ins Bürgergeld
kommen dass sie nicht die Altersvorsorge
für die sie Monate lang gespart haben
jahrelang gearbeitet haben dass die
sofort weg ist wenn sie ins Bürgergeld
kommt all das hilft selbstständigen all
das hilft freischaffenden und deswegen
ist das Bürgergeld auch mehr Sicherheit
für Kulturschaffende
es geht uns um akute Hilfe es geht uns
aber auch darum Kunst und Kultur
langfristig in Deutschland wachsen zu
lassen und zu stärken und genau das
macht Claudia Roth jetzt mit einem ganz
großartigen Projekt wir werden den
Kulturpass auf den Weg bringen und haben
dafür 100 Millionen Euro in diesem
Haushalt zur Verfügung gestellt wenn
Jugendliche 18 Jahre alt werden dann
soll jede und jeder 200 € bekommen um
damit Kultur vor Ort zu erleben das ist
für Jugendliche so wichtig die gerade in
der corona-zeit kein Leid Konzert
erleben konnten die gerade in der
coronazeit keine Lesungen in der Kneipe
erleben konnten so viel nicht erleben
konnten und nach dieser coronazeit bei
Jugendlichen die Lust an Kultur zu
wecken ihnen Zugänge dazu zu geben die
Vielfalt der kulturellen Landschaft vor
Ort zu erleben all das machen wir jetzt
und schaffen mit dem kulturpassen sein
großartiger Fortschritt den die
kulturstaatsministerin hier in
Deutschland auf den Weg bringen wird in
Frankreich gibt's das seit langem jetzt
tot Claudia das nach Deutschland sein
großer Schritt für die Kulturbranche
hier im Land
der Haushalt
2023 ist der erste den die
ampelregierung ohne und auch das
Parlament hier ohne Vorarbeit der alten
großen Koalition auf den Weg gebracht
hat und jetzt sieht man immer deutlicher
den Kurswechsel den wir machen wir haben
uns auf den Weg gemacht
Klimapolitik endlich konsequent zum Teil
von Kulturpolitik zu machen ich möchte
dass seinem Beispiel deutlich machen was
beim museum des 20 Jahrhunderts am
Berliner Kulturforum geplant wurde hat
klimapolitisch nichts mit einem
Kulturbau des 21 jahrhunderts zu tun so
wie das Museum ursprünglich gedacht war
ist es ein einziger klimaalbraum zum
Vergleich es würde ca viermal so viel
Energie verbrauchen wie das Alte Museum
hier in Berlin nur dass das Alte Museum
200 Jahre alt ist und daran sieht man
eins das ist ein Beispiel für eine ganz
spezielle Haltung die wir in den letzten
Jahren Jahrzehnten deswegen haben wir
haben als Gesellschaft so geplant so
gebaut so gelebt als wären wir die
Könige der Welt so geplant und gebaut
als gäbe es unbegrenzt billige Energie
als gäbe es die Klimakrise nicht als
gäbe es keinen Morgen mehr damit muss
Schluss sein das kann so nicht
weitergehen deswegen werden wir umplanen
und deswegen stellen wir eben Etat 10
Millionen genau dafür zur Verfügung wir
werden neu planen neu bauen und das
Nötigste angeziel ist es ein Kulturbau
zu haben der mit seinem Energiehunger
nicht mehr dazu beiträgt dass wir die
Lebensgrundlagen die auf den auf die wir
angewiesen sind zerstören und damit geht
eins einher das muss eine Wegmarke sein
dafür dass wir in Zukunft nicht mehr so
bleiben nicht mehr so bauen dürfen
sondern klimapolitisch den nächsten
Schritt in der Kulturpolitik gehen
nicht zuletzt Kulturpolitik ist immer
auch demokratiepolitik wenn Menschen
sich abends zum Singen treffen wenn
Menschen im Kur zusammenkommen dann gibt
es ein Gefühl ein Gefühl gemeinsam etwas
zu schaffen und deswegen haben wir zwei
neue Fonds auf den Weg gebracht zum
einen einen Fond für amateurmusik 5
Millionen stellen wir dafür zur
Verfügung und zum anderen ein Festival
Förderfonds ebenfalls 5 Millionen Euro
wenn Menschen gemeinsam Kultur erleben
wenn Menschen gemeinsam etwas
unternehmen dann sind das nicht die
Menschen die am Ende denen
hinterherlaufen die Hass verbreiten und
Menschen gegeneinander Aufwickeln
insofern dieser Etat ist ein krisenetats
ein klimapolitischer Etat und ist auch
ein Etat für mehr Demokratie in
Deutschland
Andreas audresch
stellvertretendervorsitzender der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen in der
der Generaldebatte des Bundestags in dem
es auch viel über und um Energie Energie
Sicherheit und Energieversorgung geht
und wenn sie gelegentlich sehen dass sie
Abgeordnete und oder sogar Ministerinnen
jetzt etwas besser eingepackt sind als
sie das gewohnt sind dann liegt das
daran dass auch hier im Bundestag die
Temperatur runter geregelt wurde
hintergrund ist die Energieversorgung
Sicherungsmaßnahmen Verordnung 19 Grad
gelten jetzt hier im Plenarsaal des
Deutschen Bundestages also auch recht
frisch Otto Fricke ist am Pool der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
Haushalt und das muss man das muss man
und ich versuche es vermitteln zu sagen
ist ein Haushalt des Übergangs wir
kommen aus einer Zeit in der uns mit
Corona und den Folgen unzugleich mit dem
was Russland Angriffskrieg gegen Bio
keine führt viele Probleme auf einmal in
unseren Haushalt hineingekommen sind
Corona gleitet hoffentlich aus kostet
aber noch und die Auswirkungen dessen
was Russland macht erleben wir noch an
vielen Ecken und Enden und dennoch ist
es uns gelungen und viele werden jetzt
sagen ja das ist euch so wichtig ja das
ist wichtig und dennoch ist es uns
gelungen im Kernhaushalt die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und
gleichzeitig für die notwendigen Dinge
die wir sowohl im Bereich Verteidigung
als auch in der Frage Elektrizität Wärme
haben in Sondervermögen Sicherheit zu
geben und das sage ich an auch deutlich
meine Richtung cducsu
euer reden sei ja ja nein nein aber
nicht immer dieses Mischmasch vor ein
paar Monaten hieß es noch diese
Koalition ist nicht in der Lage die
notwendigen Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen dann stellen wir mit den 200
Milliarden die Mittel zur Verfügung was
sagt die zu ja aber wir wissen ja noch
gar nicht genau wofür jetzt kommen wir
mit den Vorschlägen genau wofür und
jetzt sagt ihr wer das passt uns
eigentlich gar nicht das ist keine
Oppositionspolitik das ist
obstruktionspolitik und mehr ist es an
der Stelle nicht und zum Thema ob die
Schuldenbremse wirkt oder nicht alle die
cdu/csu sagt die wird nicht DIE LINKE
sagt doch die wirkt das ist ja ganz
schlimm wir können immer noch nicht mehr
ausgeben und ich will es als Haushälter
mal vorsichtig mit Blick auf die
Regierungsbank so formulieren hätte es
die Schuldenbremse nicht in diesem
Haushalt gegeben wäre ich mir sicher
hätte es noch ganz viele Wünsche gegeben
die noch in diesen Haushalt
hineingekommen sind insofern sorgt die
Schuldenbremse an der Stelle dafür dass
wir da wo es notwendig ist durch
verstärkte Mittel sichern aber
gleichzeitig im nächsten Jahr auch sagen
wohin die Reise mit dieser Koalition
geht nämlich in Richtung Stabilität bei
gleichzeitig ausreichender Versorgung in
all den Bereichen wo wir es in einer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft machen müssen
und Herr Kollege Domen da ist auch
nichts in dem Schattenhaushalt woher hat
denn die cdu/csu die ganzen Zahlen naja
ich hoffe jedenfalls deshalb weil sie
einfach mal den Haushalt gucken muss
alles das das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr die 200 werden alles da steht
da drin da ist nichts im Schatten es sei
denn man ist nicht in der Lage bei Licht
im Haushalt ein wenig nachzulesen so und
dann komme ich und dann komme ich noch
zu einer Sache mit ihren angeblich 500
Milliarden das will ich dann auch mal
sagen ich habe ja erst gedacht ich mache
ein Milchmädchen Vergleich der ist aber
erstens falsch zweitens passt er nicht
drittens wäre es eine Beleidigung mit
Adam Riese das klappt aber auch nicht
denn der ist ja selbst aus Bayern nach
Thüringen ausgewandert also geht das
auch nicht meine Damen und Herren wenn
sie sagen es sind 500 Milliarden neue
Schulden dann haben sie immer noch nicht
den verstanden was der Unterschied
zwischen einer schönen Ermächtigung ist
um im Notfall ausreichend zu haben und
was was tatsächliche Schulen sind aber
gehen wir mal in die Mathematik des
Kollegen Dobrindt und des Kollegen Merz
dann ist die Rekordverschuldung in dem
Jahr gekommen als wir 600 Milliarden im
Rahmen von corona-hilfen für WSF zur
Verfügung gestellt haben Herr Kollege
Dobrindt wenn sie schon solche komischen
Rechnungen machen weil sie an
oppositions-ehrlich machen
so und dann komme ich noch zu der Frage
und das will ich dann hier auch noch
abwarten zu der berühmten Kiste mit den
Immobilien und der Frage warum das in
der Erbschaftsteuer hochgeht wer hat uns
den Mist denn eingebrockt
dieser Herr Seehofer der die
immobilienverordnung geben
immobilienwertverordnung erhöht hat der
war es dessen Mist müssen wir jetzt
wegräumen das ist der Grund
das schon schlimm und dann will ich zum
Schluss doch noch mal bei der Frage wie
sich verhalten etwas sagen und ich
empfehle das allen weil man immer denkt
auch das ist so old style das ist so
nämlich da liegen draußen doch immer
noch die Änderungsanträge da sagt die
CDU CSU sparen sparen sparen ihr macht
das schlecht und dann geht man draußen
rum und guckt einfach noch mal ich nehme
mir mal die Anträge dann wieder liegen
und das sind nur die die bis heute
Mittag da sind die Änderungsantrag der
cdu/csu 18 Millionen nicht einsparen
mehr ausgeben Antrag der CDU CSU 150
Millionen nicht einsparen mehr ausgeben
andere Ziele CSU 40 Millionen nicht
einsparen mehr ausgeben unter der
cdu/csu 188 Millionen nochmal 20
Millionen nicht einsparen mehr ausgeben
mir fällt dazu nur König Claudius ein
erster Akt zweite Szene mit einem
heiteren und einem nassen Auge um es
deutlich zu sagen heiter wenn ich sehe
dass die Mathematik einfach nicht mehr
herrschen und im Nassen Auge dass wir
eine so schlechte Opposition haben aber
so ist es dann wohl wir werden auf jeden
Fall gucken müssen und dafür verwende
ich die letzte Minute vor Patienten wir
müssen jetzt gucken was im nächsten Jahr
notwendig ist und dass der einzige Punkt
wo ich dem Kollegen März zustimmen kann
es wird um ein Wettrennen in dieser sich
verändernden Welt gehen wo und wie
investiert wird und das sage ich
ausdrücklich wo und wie in
Nachhaltigkeit in Demografie in
Digitalisierung investiert wird wenn wir
das nicht schaffen hier an der Stelle
der
Ort auch in Demokratie mehr kann man
investieren und zwar dadurch dass man
Arbeitsplätze schaffen weil das das
essenziellste überhaupt ist dafür dass
unsere Sozialsysteme funktionieren aber
ich will es deutlich sagen die Aufgabe
für uns alle auch mit schlechter
Rechenfähigkeit wird sein wie wir dafür
sorgen dass wir der Welt sagen hier
lohnt es sich zu investieren hier
entsteht die Zukunft hier entsteht
Nachhaltigkeit hier findet
Digitalisierung statt weil wir
verstanden haben was diese zeitenwände
bedeutet herzlichen Dank
Otto Fricke war das der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion und nach Alice im
Wunderland und Jim Knopf sind wir jetzt
auch bei Hamlet angekommen so gut wie
keine Rede von Otto Fricke im Deutschen
Bundestag ohne Shakespeare Zitat diesmal
hat der König Claudius wie gesagt aus
dem Hamlet bemüht hier geht es weiter
mit Kirsten radomsky aus der
Unionsfraktion
ich muss kurz auf den Kollegen Fricke
eingehen ja Herr Fricke sie haben ja
gerade hier mehrere Papiere hochgehoben
und uns vorgeworfen wir würden nur Geld
ausgeben ich weiß nicht was Ihr Anliegen
an der Stelle ist wenn Ihr Wunsch
tatsächlich ist dass wir die über 200
Anträge die wir im Haushalts ausgestoß
gestellt haben dann auch noch mal als
Änderungsanträge ins Plenum einbringen
dann verlagern wir sicherlich die Arbeit
die wir in den Ausschüssen machen in den
Plenarsaal und da das ja auch alles
Papier ist wie sie gerade richtig
festgehalten haben halte ich das nicht
für sinnvoll wir haben die Punkte
gesetzt als Fraktion wo wir sagen das
sind wichtige Punkte an denen hätten wir
etwas anders gemacht das müssen Sie
nicht teilen
zum zweiten Mal beraten wir jetzt über
den Einzelplan des Bundeskanzlers und
von vielen darin enthaltenen
Themenfeldern von Ostdeutschland bis zur
Integration möchte ich zu Beginn auf die
Kultur eingehen Frau Roth in aktuellen
Zeit bewegten Zeiten sind die deutlichen
Erhöhungen im Etat der
kulturstaatsministerin aus meiner Sicht
ein wichtiges Zeichen deshalb liebe
Koalitionsfraktionen betrachten Sie es
jetzt mal als positives Signal von uns
dass wir im Rahmen des
Haushaltsverfahren einigen ihrer
Projekten auch zugestimmt haben hierbei
möchte ich auf die wichtige
Digitalisierung der Dokumentation von
ns-
an anderen Stellen Herr audritsch
konnten wir umso weniger zustimmen
gerade bei vermeintlich wohlklingenden
Projekten denn wir als Opposition
schauen ganz genau hin was sie da machen
etwa bei dem von Ihnen geplanten
Kulturpass der insbesondere jungen
Menschen den Zugang zur Kultur
ermöglichen soll verstehen Sie mich
jetzt hier an dieser Stelle bitte nicht
falsch grundsätzlich ist die Idee
Menschen oder junge Menschen für Kultur
zu begeistern ja gut aber wie bei allen
Dingen geht es natürlich und das ist die
entscheidende Frage um das wie
beim Wii halten wir es tatsächlich für
schwierig die 100 Millionen Euro
einzustellen wenn noch kein Plan
vorliegt und die Koalitionspartner im
Ausschuss offensichtlich
unterschiedlicher Ansicht über die
Ausgestaltung sind sie handeln hier nur
nach dem Motto wenn schon kein Plan dann
wenigstens Geld einstellen dies ist ein
Beispiel dafür dass die Bundesregierung
und die sie tragenden Fraktionen leider
konzeptlos sind an der ein oder anderen
Stelle was fehlt ist ein echter Kompass
statt Schlagworte wie Wien culture mit
denen einige wohl meinen bestimmte
Klientel zu befriedigen
statt ihren Kompass zu justieren begeben
Sie sich auf die Spielwiese der
Symbolpolitik Frau Staatsministerin das
Land und die Menschen haben derzeit viel
drängendere Probleme als eine Debatte
über die Kuppel des Berliner Schlosses
aus unserer Sicht wenden sie dem
christlichen Spruch und dessen
Überblendung zu viel Aufmerksamkeit zu
und dann auch wieder ohne konkrete
Kosten benennen zu können
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben ein
Recht darauf dass in angespannten Zeiten
der Fokus auf das wirklich notwendige
gerichtet wird doch die em-ampelmehrheit
hat unseren maßgabebeschluss gegen die
Verwendung von Haushaltsmitteln zu
diesem Zweck abgelehnt
an anderer Stelle dann wieder fehlt es
an Aufmerksamkeit und dementsprechend
weil wir über den Etat sprechen auch an
Geld
ich möchte einige schlaglichte aufwerfen
die wir als cdu/csu-fraktion für wichtig
befunden hätten den sie leider nicht
zugestimmt haben ein aufwuchs beim
Zukunftsprogramm Kino eine Erhöhung der
Mittel für das ostpreußische
Landesmuseum weitere Mittel für die
Deutsche Welle zugunsten ukrainisch und
russischsprachiger Angebote und 500.000
Euro für das geplante Mahnmal für die
Opfer kommunistischer Gewaltherrschaft
in Deutschland das sind nur einige
unsere Vorschläge Herr Fricke die wir im
Ausschuss gemacht haben für den
Kulturetat aber ich möchte am Ende
vielleicht auch noch auf das vielleicht
strittigste Thema in diesem Einzelplan
kommen
den geplanten Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzleramts den der Bundeskanzler
und seine Behörde unbedingt in dieser
Größenordnung realisieren wollen
wir als Union haben uns gegen den Bau in
dieser Form und die Kostensteigerung
inklusive Risikokosten von 777 Millionen
ausgesprochen denn
seit der Planung hat sich viel verändert
wenn sie mir jetzt nicht zuhören und die
ganze Zeit schreien können sie ja meine
Argumentation gar nicht nachvollziehen
der 24 Februar diesen Jahres steht für
einen tiefen Einschnitt von der
Haushaltspolitik bis zur
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Lage nachdem wir
im September über die Mehrkosten
informiert worden haben wir gefordert
neue Einsparpotenziale zu treffen um die
Kosten zu dämpfen die Ampel hat
abgelehnt
in angespannten Zeiten mit besonderen
finanziellen Herausforderungen ich nehme
beispielhaft das Stichwort
Sondervermögen plädieren wir für eine
Verschiebung der Baumaßnahme wenn eine
Reduzierung der Kosten angeblich nicht
möglich ist
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler schön
dass sie wieder da sind ihr
Kanzleramtschef hat uns hausheltern
mitgeteilt dass sie im Februar
entschieden haben dass dieser Bau gebaut
also dass die der Erweiterungsbau jetzt
umgesetzt werden soll ich gehe davon aus
dass das vor ihrer Rede vom
27.02.2022 war und es würde von
Vorbildfunktion und politischer Weisheit
Zeugen getroffene Entscheidungen
aufgrund der neuen Situation zu
überdenken und dem Wort Zeitenwende
Taten folgen zu lassen vielen Dank
Kerstin Radomski ist wirklich dem
Haushaltsausschuss und in der
cdu/csu-fraktion und auch sie hat
geredet hier in der Debatte zum
Kanzleramt und Bundeskanzler die ja die
Generaldebatte ist in einer
haushaltswoche jetzt die SPD-Vorsitzende
Saskia esken
am Samstag jährte sich die
Bundestagswahl mit der Willy Brandt 1972
als Kanzler der Bundesrepublik bestätigt
wurde 50 Jahre ist das jetzt her viele
Zitate brennt aus dieser Zeit sind
legendär dazu gehört natürlich auch sein
Appell mehr Demokratie zu wagen denn das
ist sie unsere Demokratie sie ist ein
Wagnis
DemokratInnen und Demokraten gehen in
Wagnis an wenn Sie Politik offen und
partizipativ gestalten wenn sie
multipolare wenn sie lagerübergreifende
Koalitionen mit Demokraten eingehen denn
das bedeutet geteilte macht als wahre
Macht zu begreifen im Inneren wie im
äußeren die Demokratie ist also ein
Wagnis und gleichzeitig ist sie wie Rolf
Mütze nicht gerade ganz richtig gesagt
hat unsere einzige Hoffnung unser
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zeigt eine
solche wagemutige hoffnungsfrohe
demokratische Gesinnung an jedem Tag und
mit großen Erfolg in der Führung der
Ampel ebenso wie auf den internationalen
Bühnen
und es ist kein Zufall dass der
Koalitionsvertrag den wir vor einem Jahr
geschlossen haben den Titel trägt mehr
Fortschritt Wagen als ich für die SPD
diesen Vertrag unterzeichnet habe da
waren mir zwei Dinge besonders wichtig
erstens wir formulieren den Anspruch
dieses Land zu modernisieren denn
Wirtschaftsstandort und die Gesellschaft
fit zu machen für die Zukunft in
Anerkennung der Realität und den Mitten
der Krisen die wir erleben und
bewältigen müssen mit aktiver
Industriepolitik mit einer sicheren und
bezahlbaren Energieversorgung und nicht
zuletzt mit einer Strategie zur
Bewältigung des Fachkräftemangels denn
das ist die Achillesferse unserer
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
zweitens geht es mir geht es uns um
Respekt Respekt für jeden Menschen
Respekt für jeden Abschluss für jede
Tätigkeit und deshalb haben wir den
Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht wir
senken die Abgaben für geringe Einkommen
unter 2.000 Euro damit sich Leistung
lohnt und wir modernisieren unseren
Sozialstaat das neue Bürgergeld bedeutet
zusammen mit der Ausweitung des
wohngelds und der wesentlichen Erhöhung
von Kindergeld und Kinderzuschlag die
größte sozialstaatsreform seit 20 Jahren
wir wollen eine Sozialstaat der Menschen
auf Augenhöhe begegnet und sie
bestmöglich und ganz individuell dabei
unterstützt ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
zu führen egal ob sie arbeiten doch der
Lohn ihrer Arbeit reicht nicht zum Leben
ob sie erwerbslos sind doch es fehlt
ihnen die Qualifikation ob sie in
Ausbildung sind oder ob sie eine Chance
im sozialen Arbeitsmarkt brauchen denn
so vielfältig sind die Lebenssituationen
von Menschen in Grundsicherung wir
werden ihnen gerecht und stärken ihre
Teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen Leben das
ist für mich Respekt
ganz klar haben wir mit der Reform des
Bürgergeldes im Blick das Erwerbslose
Menschen in Arbeit kommen aber
nachhaltig und nicht nur so dass sie in
einer ewigen Drehtür zwischen prekärer
Arbeit und Jobcenter gefangen sind und
deshalb stellen wir Qualifikationen
jetzt in den Vordergrund schaffen den
vermittlungsvorgang ab und schaffen ein
Ausbildungsbonus und ein
Weiterbildungsgeld im Kern bedeutet
dieses Bürgergeld also mehr Geld mehr
Teilhabe mehr Qualifikation und mehr
Respekt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Respekt
für jedermann und jede Frau das
beinhaltet auch Respekt vor anderen
Meinungen und Perspektiven bevor sie zu
Tumult gibt auf der rechten Seite des
Parlaments nein sie sind damit nicht
gemeint es gibt keine Toleranz und es
gibt keinen Respekt für die Intoleranz
und ihr Hass ist keine Meinung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
Respekt und mit ehrlichem Interesse an
der Auffassung anderer haben wir diese
Koalition gebildet dass wir unsere
Vorhaben gemeinsam so voranbringen dass
niemand mit der Faust in der Tasche zur
Abstimmung gehen muss das ist eine
besondere Qualität der Arbeit in dieser
Koalition und dafür gilt mein ganz
herzlicher Dank den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die in der Regierung und die im
parlamentarischen Verfahren immer wieder
und jeden Tag daran arbeiten dass das
gelingt und zwar sowohl in der
Bewältigung der multiplen Krisen als
auch in der Modernisierung unseres
Landes und in der Stärkung des
Zusammenhalts vielen Dank
[Applaus]
SPD-Vorsitzende in der Debatte in der
Generaldebatte in der haushaltswoche zum
Bundeshaushalt 2023 und da hören wir
jetzt Martin Erwin Renner aus der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
geht nicht hoch verehrtes Präsidium sehr
geehrte Damen sehr geehrte Herren wir
sprechen über den Haushalt der
Bundesbeauftragten für Kultur und Medien
diejenige die so gerne die Inschrift an
der Kuppel des Berliner Stadtschlosses
überblenden würde oder so wie die
parteigen uns in Werbung das historische
Ratsfrau Kreuz in Münster zum Treffen
der G7 Außenminister entfernt ist ist
das was unsere deutsche Kultur und unser
christliches geprägte Nation tatsächlich
blüht wenn der Schutz unserer Kultur in
die Verantwortung von Grünen und Linken
kulturleugnen ein Heim gegeben wird die
weniger das Fremde so sehr lieben als
das eigene so sehr hassen dann wird hier
nicht für die Pflege und den Erhalt der
Kultur Sorge getragen und unsere Kultur
und unsere Identität wird
parteipolitisch umgedeutet umgeschrieben
und in einen ideologischen grünen linken
geisteskäfig eingepfercht
es ist noch niemals
eine Geld in die Pflege eines Gartens zu
stecken indem man vorher den Bock zum
Gärtner gemacht hat was hier am Ende
übrig bleibt schmeckt bestenfalls den
Box selbst und auch seiner gefräßigen
Herde wir sehen doch überall eine sich
selbst festklebende ja die Kulturgüter
beschmutzt und auch Menschenleben
gefährdet die uns ihre linksideologische
Schmalspur Weltsicht aufzwingen will wir
sehen dass Kultur und Buchpreise
zunehmend nur noch für schamlose und
peinliche Individuen vergeben werden ist
das wirklich Kunst oder kann das weg
nehmen wir die Deutsche Welle das mit
immer mehr Millionen Euro Steuergeld
verwöhnt wird hier wird potenziellen
zuwandern das deutsche Paradies nahe und
ans Herz gelegt hier wird das Tragen von
Kopftüchern auch hierzulande beworben
und die Deutsche Welle engagiert sich
zudem auch im Ausland für Revolutionen
Medienkunst und Kultur müssen
staatskritisch sein das ist ihre Aufgabe
und Berufung meine Damen und Herren doch
hier wird mit dem Geld gesteuert alles
seit Jahrzehnten die Kumpanei mit der
Kultur
alimentiert die dem opportunistischen
Grundsatz kultigt bestuldig ist das Lied
ich sing und ich sage Ihnen Kumpanei ist
Lumperei
ich schließe mit einem Zitat von
Friedrich Hölderlin doch wo Gefahr ist
wächst das Retten der auch und ganz
sicher ist die deutsche Wolke
Kulturpolitik der Ampel ist nicht das
rettende sondern sie ist das sie ist die
treuende Gefahr meine Damen und Herren
danke
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun Stefan Gebhardt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
haushaltsberater Beratungen lassen sich
immer sehr unterschiedlich lesen ich
möchte jetzt eine ostdeutsche
Perspektive hinzufügen ein Beispiel noch
immer sind im Osten Löhne und Gehälter
niedriger die Vermögen und
rücklinkanlagen sind kleiner ungefähr
halb so groß im Ergebnis ist die
finanzielle Belastbarkeit zwischen
Rostock und Chemnitz auch nach 32 Jahren
Einheit deutlich geringer das führt dann
in einer Krisensituation schnell Zuhörer
und Sicherheit und das wiederum zu
lautem und lauterem Unmut deswegen ist
es wichtig hier zu signalisieren die
Ampel handelt die energiepreisbremsen
kommen gut so das 49 Euro bundesticket
kommt gut so das Kindergeld wird erhöht
gut so
damit sind nicht alle Probleme gelöst
dann wären sie das je aber dieser
Haushalt gibt vielen Menschen halt das
Parlament hat gearbeitet der
angekündigte heiße Herbst der bleibt
doch recht kühl
jene die die Unsicherheit und den Unmut
gerade im Osten für ihre ganz eigene
Agenda instrumentalisieren ja
missbrauchen wollten schauen ziemlich in
die Röhre und auch da sage ich gut so
ein weiteres Signal mit dem Bürgergeld
kann ein ostdeutsches Trauma ein Stück
weit ein Stück weit abgestreift werden
das heißt keine Entwarnung aber machen
wir uns das noch mal bewusst nach dem
krassen Umbrüchen der 90er Jahre mit
galoppierende Arbeitslosigkeit für die
Arbeitslosenhilfe ersatzlos weg
entflecht Entrechtung und öffentliche
Geringschätzung taten dann ihr Werk
viele Menschen und ihm
überdurchschnittlich viele Menschen im
Osten wurden dazu gebracht auch jedem
noch so unpassenden und mies bezahlten
Job anzunehmen diesen Zustand zu
verlassen das ist ein Schritt den
weitere folgen müssen
warum aber nun wurden wieder 49 Euro
bundesticket noch energiepreisbremse
Bürgergeld oder Kindergeld warum wurde
all das bislang kaum unter dem Ost-West
Unterschieden betrachtet es vielen
Ostdeutsche reflexions- und
debattenräume um Interesse und
Bewusstsein zu verankern zu wecken sich
explizit als ostdeutsch bezeichnende
Medien vielen weiterhin zum Vergleich
Nordwest und Süddeutsche Medien bekennen
sich dazu schon in ihrem Namen
ostdeutsche überhaupt nicht das ist ein
gesellschaftlicher wegfehler mit dem
transformationszentrum ist ein
reflexions- und der breiten Raum geplant
mit den Campus der Demokratie ein
weiterer auf dem Weg ich kann da die
Bundesregierung nur ermutigen rasch und
konsequent diesen Weg zu gehen denn
Vertrauen in den Staat in die
Institutionen und die Menschen die diese
prägen das muss verdient werden dazu
braucht es einen funktionierenden und
handelnden Staat dazu braucht es
Identifikation dazu braucht es
Repräsentanz das macht sich fest an den
Institutionen vor Ort
das macht sich fest an der Sichtbarkeit
von Personen im und aus dem Osten und
damit eben auch in Schlüsselpositionen
Gesichter und Geschichten das braucht es
und finanzielle Widerstandsfähigkeit
unabhängig von den Himmelsrichtungen
durch das konsequente Angleichen der
einkommens- und Vermögensverhältnisse
das geht nicht mit einem Haushalt das
bedarf weiterer struktureller
Veränderung und eben dieses Bewusstsein
diese östliche Perspektive auch übrigens
über und die Grenzen unserer Republik
hinaus es ist zum Beispiel sehr stark
dass wir ein deutsch-französisches
Bahnticket für die Jugend hier auf dem
Weg bringen dem muss nun ein eben
solches deutsch-polnisches Ticket folgen
oder in Deutschland
das ist dann eben diese Perspektive
dieses Bewusstsein und das ist auch
2023 ein Arbeitsauftrag an alle von uns
vielen Dank
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Thomas Hacker das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Kultur
Deutschland ist eine Kulturnation fragt
man die Menschen auf der Straße was
Kultur für sie ausmacht wird man viele
Antworten erhalten graphic nobles
nft-kunst in Bayreuth vielleicht
wagner-obern Literatur und Musik von
Klassik bis Pop Plattdeutsch oder
Ballett dazu die breiten kulturellen
Traditionen die Menschen aus ihren
Heimatländern mit nach Deutschland
gebracht haben Kultur und ihre
Ausdrucksformen sind so vielfältig wie
die Menschen die sie erreichen deutlich
ist ihr Beitrag jedoch zu unserem
gesellschaftlichen Miteinander
vielleicht mag man sogar von einem
Beitrag zur Zivilisation sprechen auch
wenn das das war ein strittig diskutiert
wird der Soziologe Dirk Becker fasst es
in einem esse zur corona-krise meines
Empfindens nach Treffen zusammen ich
zitiere
der wichtigste Beitrag der Kultur
besteht darin für eine Qualität der
Begegnung des Gesprächs der Debatte zu
sorgen die es erlaubt sich im besten
Sinne des Wortes zivilisiert zu
verständigen und darum geht es
und darum geht es uns in der Ampel in
diesen umwälzenden Zeiten angesichts der
großen gesellschaftlichen
Bewährungsproben die wir haben die
coronakrise ist im Kulturbetrieb noch
nicht ganz überwunden und morgen sind es
bereits neun Monate in denen der
völkerrechtswidrige Russlands gegen die
Ukraine in Europa tobt der
Bundeshaushalt
2023 setzt ein entschlossenes Zeichen
für Kultur und für Familien
wo andere den Rotstift ansetzen würden
stellen wir erneut mehr Geld bereit
dafür danke ich Christian Lindner und
Claudia Roth und den Haushältern
ausdrücklich so können wir die
kulturpolitischen Schwerpunkte unserer
gemeinsamen Koalition fortsetzen wir
setzen aber gleichzeitig auch neue
Impulse der Kulturpass richtet sich
besonders an die junge Generation gerade
sie liebe Union waren es doch die in den
letzten zwei Jahren der Pandemie die
großen Leidtragenden waren die
Faszination von
live-kulturerlebnissen können durch
YouTube Netflix oder
nicht wirklich dauerhaft kompensiert
werden ja Kultur braucht Investitionen
Investitionen im Kulturdenkmäler wie die
Andreaskapelle in Bamberger Dom oder in
Kulturorte wie das Kino International
hier in Berlin mit dem Haushalt kommen
wir aber auch unsere
erinnerungskulturellen Verantwortung
nach in einer digitalen Welt muss die
Auseinandersetzung mit und die
Erinnerung an die NS-Verbrechen auch im
digitalen Raum stattfinden hier können
wir die junge Generation erreichen und
für die unvorstellbaren
zivilisationsbrüche in unserer
Geschichte sensibilisieren
unsere erinnerungskulturelle Verhandlung
gilt auch für die Jahrzehnte in einem
getrennten und schließlich
wiedervereinten Deutschland wir stärken
nicht allein die Arbeit von
Gedenkstätten und Institutionen sondern
auch die Bereitstellung eines digitalen
kollektiven Gedächtnisses mit 13,5
Milliarden kann das
Bundesarchiv auch in den nächsten Jahren
die vorhandenen Dokumente der
Staatssicherheit der DDR digitalisieren
und für die Nachwelt erhalten für uns
bleibt der aufrichtige Blick in die
Vergangenheit die Voraussetzung für die
demokratische Gestaltung unserer Zukunft
über den einen oder anderen Antrag den
wir heute auch beraten kann man nur den
Kopf schütteln es ist zwar richtig dass
man mal für die Opfer kommunistischer
Gewaltherrschaft in Deutschland zu
unterstützen wer dafür aber die Deutsche
Welle kürzen will hat die Zeichen der
Zeit nicht erkannt
die Deutsche Welle
die Deutsche Welle hat einen
entscheidenden Anteil daran unsere
gemeinsamen europäischen Werte unsere
Demokratie unsere Kultur unsere Freiheit
in die Welt hinauszutragen sie hilft
exil-journalisten und Journalisten
genauso ihre Arbeit fortzusetzen sich
dem russischen Diktator entgegenstellen
zu können liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundeshaushalt 23 schafft die
richtigen Voraussetzung die kulturelle
Vielfalt zu stärken die
Kulturschaffenden zu unterstützen
Menschen die vor dem Krieg fliehen
Hoffnung zu geben so kann die Kultur und
der letzte Satz Frau Präsident ihre
Wirkung entfalten ihren Beitrag leisten
für eine freie und zivilisierte Welt
vielen Dank
Thomas Hacker war das FDP-Fraktion
medienpolitischer Sprecher dort und sie
haben es wahrscheinlich gemerkt haben
andererseits wissen sie es ohnehin schon
zum Etat von Bundeskanzleramt und
Bundeskanzler gehört auch der Etat für
die Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für
Kultur und Medien Claudia Roth deswegen
spielt hier auch Kulturförderung und die
Stiftung Preußischer Kultur Besitz
beispielsweise eine Rolle in den Reden
zu in dieser Generaldebatte Sepp Müller
ist ja nächste Redner stell einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Unionsfraktion
die scheinbar diese Koalition
zusammenhält ist der Kit der Schulden
fast 500 Milliarden Euro neue Schulden
das nimmt diese ampelregierung auf das
sind so viele Schulden wie die
Bundesregierungen zwischen
1949 bis 1990 insgesamt aufgenommen
haben das geht zu Lasten unserer Kinder
und Enkelkinder hier kann ich nur den
Kopf schütteln Herr Bundeskanzler
Deutschland kann wesentlich mehr nicht
mehr Schulden sondern mehr Unterstützung
ein positives Momentum an Unterstützung
gibt es für den Osten mit dem
Bundeshaushalt tatsächlich es wird
zusätzliches Geld für eine Pipeline
zwischen Rostock und Schwedt aufgenommen
das war es dann aber auch schon und
dabei gibt es doch so vieles mehr was
ihr liebe Ampel auch mit wenig Geld
verbessern könnt dieses Land ist
gegängelt von Bürokratie es braucht eine
Entbürokratisierung und ein schnelleres
und effektiveres Planungsverfahren wo
ist euer Sommerpaket diese Lösung ist
nicht nur unkompliziert diese Lösung
kostet kein Geld es kann doch nicht sein
dass wir einerseits innerhalb von acht
Monaten ein lg-terminell in die Nordsee
rammen auf der anderen Seite schaffen
wir es aber nicht innerhalb von acht
Monaten eine zusätzliche Pipeline
zwischen Rostock und Schwedt in die Erde
zu bringen da müssen sie handeln Liebe
Bundesregierung
hier steht nicht nur die
Energiesicherheit für ganz
Ostdeutschland auf dem Spiel nein es
steht die Energieversorgung für ganz
Mittel und Ostdeutschland auf dem Spiel
die Sie zu verantworten haben Herr
Bundeskanzler ich sehe schon jetzt die
verblüfften Gesichter Anfang nächsten
Jahres wenn die Preise an der Tankstelle
durch die Decke gehen
vorausgesetzt es kommt bis dahin
überhaupt noch aus jedem Hahn Sprit
diese Regierung ist nicht in der Lage
dazu die infrastrukturellen
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen das Schwedt
ab dem 1 Januar 2023 auch weiteren
ausreichend bedrohölversorgt werden kann
in einem deutschlandfunk-interview vom
Juni diesen Jahr dieses Jahres kündigte
Wirtschaftsminister habe ich an die
Kartellbehörde mit ausreichend klauen
und Zehen auszustatten Minister Habeck
hat angekündigt möglichst schnell
Vorschläge zu einem schärferen
Kartellrecht vorzulegen
bis heute funktioniert in der Umsetzung
davon nichts und wieder nichts im Juni
das ist möglichst schnell Herr Habig
nach ihrem Zeitverständnis fährt die
Deutsche Bahn pünktlich wir werden in
energiepolitisch schwierigen Zeiten
übergehen wenn kein russisches Öl mehr
in Deutschland ankommen doch ihre
ampelregierung vorneweg die
bundesaußenministerin Annalena baerbock
spricht öffentlich davon ich zitiere nie
wieder Öl nie wieder Gas aus Russland
das halte ich für falsch es wird eine
Zeit nach dem Kriegstreiber Putin geben
darauf müssen wir vorbereitet sein es
braucht nicht nur eine china-strategie
nein wir müssen Griff schnellstmöglich
einen Russland planen griffbereit in der
Schublade haben was ist wenn endlich
dieser verbrecherische Angriffskrieg
vorbei ist was ist wenn Putin im
Dezember hoffentlich nicht mehr im Amt
ist werden wir dann wieder Öl und Gas
aus Russland beziehen wollen ist es
sinnvoll Russland in die Arme von China
zu treiben ist es sinnvoll insbesondere
den von Deutschlands und deren Industrie
auf energiepolitisch unsichere Füße zu
stellen lassen Sie mich beim Thema
Energiesicherheit eines nochmal ganz
klar betonen Habeck mit ihrem Ziel
bereits 2030 aus der Kohle auszusteigen
gefährfern sie nicht nur die
Energiesicherheit Ostdeutschlands sie
stellen tausende von Arbeitnehmerinnen
und Arbeitnehmern vor ungewisse Zukunft
die SPD sagte vorhin Herr Mütze nicht
sie stehen an der Seite der
Gewerkschaften sprechen Sie mit den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der IGBCE was
erzählen sie eigentlich diesen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer deren
Zukunft sie so leichtfertig auf Spiel
setzen ihr Minister Habeck hat es nicht
einmal geschafft das vorgesehene
Gutachten zum Kohleausstieg 2038 zum 15
August diesen Jahres vorzulegen
drei von vier betroffenen Bundesländern
Kollege Mützenich von der SPD sind im
Osten sie warten auf eine Antwort
tausende Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer warten auf eine Antwort
wir brauchen alle uns zur Verfügung
stehenden Energiequellen wir sollten uns
neuen technologischen Möglichkeiten wie
der Nutzung und Speicherung von CO2 als
Rohstoff nicht verschließen so
verhindern wir ein Blackout der
Industrienation Deutschlands unabhängig
von dieser Gefahr ist es doch
bezeichnend Herr Habeck das sind eine
Umfrage der Industrie und
handelskammerhalle Dessau alle befragten
Unternehmer zum ersten Mal seit 20
Jahren eine negative Zukunftsprognose
gezeichnet haben alle Befragten seitdem
diese Ampel am Werk ist sehen wir
wirtschaftlich dunkelste Zeiten auf uns
zu wollen da sagt nicht nur die Union
und nicht nur ich um eine Stimme von der
Handelskammer zu zitieren aus offenbar
ideologischen Gründen riskiert die Ampel
lieber dass sich die Wirtschaftskrise
vehement verschärft so der
Geschäftsführer der IHK Halle Dessau
packen sie an deutschland kann mehr wir
als cdu/c Fraktion haben dazu eine Idee
wir haben einen Plan vorgelegt senken
die sie die Steuern für Unternehmer und
Unternehmer auf 25 Prozent setzen sie
sich für berufliche Weiterbildung ein
und setzen Sie sich lieber
Staatsminister Schneider endlich für den
Osten ein wir brauchen die Pipeline von
Rostock nach Schwedt damit es in Schwedt
ab 1.1 weitergeht für Ostdeutschland für
Mitteldeutschland das ist der Plan
deutschland kann mehr
[Applaus]
Sepp Müller war das für die
Unionsfraktion hier mit seiner Kritik an
dem
Haushalt auf ihn Antworten direkt kann
und Achim Post der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
lieber Kollege Müller ich hoffe sie
sehen es mir nach wenn ich so gut wie
nichts richtig fand was Sie gesagt haben
ich nehme ihn aber und das ganz ernst
gemeint ab dass sie die Sorge um die
Zukunft unseres Landes antreibt und
umtreibt dass sie eine andere Sichtweise
haben als das was die Bundesregierung
macht und das zeichnet ja solche
Debatten in diesem Parlament aus das
kann man wenn ich nach ganz rechts außen
gucke nicht von allen Rednerinnen und
reden dann sagen da ist es unter
Formulierung wie der Niedergang
Deutschlands das Ende des europäischen
Abendlandes in Niedergang der deutschen
Kultur und generell das Untergangs
Deutschlands nicht zu machen und ich
glaube lieber AFD dass sie von
Demokratie nicht viel halten das weiß
ich schon
ja liebe AFD ich bin nett ich bin nett
ich weiß dass sie von Demokratie nicht
viel halten von Deutschland von diesem
Land von unserem Land verstehen sie gar
nichts liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn dieses Land
dieses Land dieses Land Deutschland
zeigt jedes Tag aufs Neue was in ihm
steckt und was in seinen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern steckt mit Leistung Einsatz
Engagement gerade in Zeiten wie diesen
sehe ich Millionen von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und Beschäftigten die jeden Tag
was leisten und dafür sorgen dass wir
diesen Haushalt überhaupt verabschieden
können liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sonst hätte man nämlich keine über 450
Milliarden Euro für diesen Haushalt 23
und in diesem Haus gibt es wenige
jedenfalls nicht in der Ampelkoalition
bei den meisten der Kollegen der cdu/csu
auch nicht bei der Linkspartei auch
nicht die negieren die leugnen dass wir
schwierige Zeiten haben dass wir
konkrete Probleme haben und deshalb ist
es gut dass wir diese Bundesregierung
haben die packt diese Probleme nämlich
an
hohe Kosten für Energie sehr hohe Kosten
vor Energie wir gucken nicht tatenlos zu
wir legen 200 Milliarden Euro auf den
Tisch des Hauses und begrenzen den
Anstieg der Energiekosten
schwierige Lage in vielen Familien in
Deutschland ab dem ersten ersten
230 Euro für jedes Kind in Deutschland
das ist eine ganze Menge und das ist
eine ganz praktische Verbesserung der
Lebensbedingungen von vielen Familien in
Deutschland
dann zu dem was diese Bundesregierung
insgesamt leistet sie haben die
Bundeswehr vorhin angesprochen ich war
per März war es die 100 Milliarden ich
finde es lässt sich sehen wenn man in
einer sehr schwierigen Zeit 100
Milliarden Euro extra zur Ertüchtigung
und Verstärkung der Bundeswehr ausgibt
und diese Bundesregierung diese
bundesverteidigungsministerin macht das
übrigens wir haben am Anfang des Jahres
lange darüber geredet was ist eigentlich
mit Schutzausrüstung mit Schutzkleidung
jahrelang hat die
Verteidigungsministerin haben die
Verteidigungsminister der Union ist
nicht geliefert im April diesen Jahres
2,4 Milliarden Bestellung durch dieses
Verteidigungsministerium liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und diese Bundesregierung dieser
Bundeskanzler liefern nicht nur in
Deutschland sie liefern nicht nur für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger hier sie